Bonus podcast.
I don't even hear myself.
There we go.
Does that mean bone in his podcasts?
You dirty little freaks,
uh,
to Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the flashlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
It's fucking awesome product.
It's embarrassing.
It's ridiculous.
You'll feel bad once you actually come inside this thing.
It's not a proud moment.
It's not the peak of your existence.
But if you just look at it,
if you separate yourself and look at it objectively,
all it is,
is a tool that allows you to masturbate more efficiently.
And I'm a firm believer that masturbation is a certain type of body maintenance.
I think it's necessary.
So this allows you to do that better.
Just clean it and just erase,
erase bad memories.
Okay.
Entering the code name,
Rogan Kate,
you saw 15% off and go fuck that thing.
And flashlights don't fart.
They don't.
You've got foreign problems.
No,
no.
But most girls,
you know and you don't have to cuddle.
Yeah,
exactly.
I like coddling.
I don't know,
but
no,
I don't like that at all.
Still waiting for the disposable flashlight.
That's going to be big whenever they fucking have the balls to come out with
that.
I'm going to see people will wash it.
Just like you used to wash condoms.
It's got a camera.
Just make it so cheap.
That's for like a dollar 99.
You can,
you can call it a bad idea.
If it could be like five bucks,
so you can be like a chief day.
Just real quick.
I don't want to wash it.
I've tried it.
I tried the fleshlight before you even fucking,
yeah,
you told me.
Yeah,
it's true.
You actually bought one because of a bad date.
Right?
I was on a bad date.
I thought girl flu came in to visit you guys.
I met this girl online and this is back when I was a whore back in the hor days.
Um,
she looked hot on my space,
flew around and I'm like,
damn,
she looks nothing like your mind space.
That happens every now and then.
She was using some them bitches should be working for Pixar.
You know what I mean?
Then bitches from Photoshop masters when my space is big,
if you didn't have a fucking background and being a hot bitch on my space,
you're not going to get the job at fucking,
you know,
Disney or Pixar.
You know what I mean?
Those are the best.
That eight years of fucking mice space was the first time we ever encountered
someone able to completely lie about what they look like.
Damn good pitches got really good.
They didn't know shit a word or anything like open up that Photoshop they,
you have to,
it's like you have to learn how to get your nails done.
You're going to have to learn how to fuck with the Photoshop,
your photos.
A lot of girls actually became famous just through being a hot chick on my
space.
Totally.
That actually became a love my space,
so I fly this chicken and it was one of those where you fly them in for the
weekend,
you know?
I thought she was hot enough.
As soon as I picked her up the airport,
I'm like,
Damn God damn it.
She was the good pictures.
God dammit.
Good from
far,
far from God.
And so she was our eye so she wasn't eating.
This bit's,
I flew this pitch in.
If she wasn't even given me any play,
she wasn't no physical play.
Well you were probably like,
yeah,
come on in.
What's up man?
You don't want to fuck you or what?
You know what she was used to?
She was used to that.
I'm sure I wasn't the first guy.
She's just a guy's gone.
Aw,
I got my space.
Well there's a lot of also,
there's a lot of girls who feel like once they give up the pussy,
once they have sex with you,
they've lost all their power.
Their whole power is ain't no holding back something
after getting dog like six times they took,
I damn,
this sucks dude.
What is all into her,
dude,
I'll buy you this.
I'm going to do this.
I'm putting up with all of your shit.
I'm gonna get that.
And then once you bust that nut and it's Friday night,
you're like,
damn,
this bitch is going to stay here Til Sun Day and I'm done Friday.
And you know what I mean?
Yeah.
This bitch wasn't giving me any play at all.
This again,
this is back when I was a whore and I flew around just giving me no play.
So I decided to take her to the hustlers store and have her,
you know,
we ended up buying a fucking flashlight and a
good,
Laurie,
this is awesome.
I like how
fucking distance.
I didn't know.
I didn't know where to go without Jesus Christ.
So why did you step in and I don't know what happened there.
I thought it was going to end it nice.
It was a Tacos rainmaker.
We come again.
That was a door was,
but it was a bunch of light jabs and there was a big right hand come up behind
it all to Joe Rogan.
Dot.
Net experience without the fuck we're on is also brought to you by [inaudible]
some raw.
I'm not hearing well on this thing.
For some reason.
I tried to turn it up,
but it's not working.
How do I turn it up?
His father cable.
Yeah,
I did mountain stop doing shit.
It's on full blast.
You don't have your mute on maybe.
Oh,
don't have the meat on them unless it's this side.
The Alpha brain pills.
You can find out [inaudible] dot namba.com but I think I made the vote.
The input louder.
No,
can't do that.
You have that?
This is only,
no,
you can do the whole entire headphone unit.
Just headphones,
but not input.
I can't change my input.
Right.
You can change the input up everybody else's headphones by no,
no,
no.
I mean a input of the headphones.
I mean you can microphone.
No.
Okay,
so it's louder.
It's good.
Yeah,
I did.
I did it.
All right.
But if you go to [inaudible] dot net you know,
go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and and and it makers of Alpha brain,
what's Alpha brand?
It's a cognitive news,
nutrition,
whatever the fuck it is.
It's some brain pills that recently got reviewed in the Atlantic favorably.
They enjoyed them and they said that it,
it,
uh,
oh,
how dare you,
Eddie Bravo shut that shit off.
He said that,
uh,
they,
they work great for when you haven't gotten enough sleep.
And uh,
that's what I found him for as well.
Um,
I,
I love taking them on jet lag to it.
What they are as a cognitive enhancing supplement,
a supplement that allows your brain to produce more neurotransmitters.
I don't understand the science behind it,
but I've read a lot it and I tried to memorize
it but it's really just goes in one ear and out the other.
But the bottom line is we're,
we're funding a university double blind placebo tests on it from a prestigious
university in Australia.
Uh,
and uh,
there were trying to do it as scientifically as possible.
There's something to all this stuff.
There's something to nootropics you don't have to believe,
but if you're interested in Google the word nootropic,
then once you've done that,
explore all the options before you even think about buying an Alpha brain.
Try all kinds of shit buying in bulk.
And if you want to take our ingredient list just taken off and,
and it's,
it's too expensive view.
This is the best way to do it.
Steal the ingredient lists,
copy it.
That's not stealing it.
Just copy it.
You have full right to it's online.
Copy it and make it,
mix it all up yourself.
You'll save some money.
I hope you do and I hope it works.
If you don't want to do that,
we sell it.
If you buy it and you don't like it,
you get for the first order for 30 pills,
you get your money back 100% you don't even have to send the pills back.
We're trying to make it like as easy as possible.
The last thing I want is anybody to feel ripped off,
but I use this shit and I enjoy it and I think it's fucking awesome.
I love nootropics.
I've been taking nootropics before.
I got involved with Alpha brain.
I've taken a bunch of them.
They work.
There's vitamins that can enhance the way your mind operates.
You know,
it's not great.
It's not significant.
It's not going to turn a morning into a genius,
but it,
for me,
it helps me run smoother.
Uh,
but I believe in a lot of nutritional supplements.
I believe in fish oil.
I take a lot of probiotics.
I believe in a lot of things that I don't sell.
I think it's very important to take a lot of nutritious supplements.
And what happened Brian,
for scream at bright scary is this the internet see something better.
Why he's scaring me with this big bright Ufo type fucking shit by my head.
Uh,
anyway,
we also make shroom tech immune,
which is an immunity supplement.
All this is explained on,
on at.com.
And like I said,
first order,
a hundred percent money back guarantee.
We used to have it for everything,
but then some people went online and they sold it on Ebay and they got their
money back.
They hacked us,
so they win.
So now we changed it.
So that's it.
Go to [inaudible] Dot Com oh and and it entering the code name Rogan.
Oh,
and by the way,
it's only for your first order.
After that you got to pay full price.
The codename Rogan.
Apparently it's only good for one time.
I should probably try to have that for change,
right?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I should.
Right.
Okay,
I'll do that.
That's it.
Good.
I chose over.
Listen.
[inaudible] dirty bitches.
The Internet has made something happen.
We've pulled together in less than 24 hours.
No other interaction with this young man.
But the Internet's a man
and that
stupid cat.
You're not a DJ.
[inaudible]
that's the professor.
That's the actual video.
That's the way the video looks.
Is there a way you can shut those music off where it doesn't do this for 10
minutes?
What is this?
This is my fate out.
This is terrible,
right?
We got to stop speaking dizzy for real.
It's really obnoxious.
There you go.
So was that the actual video,
the music video?
No,
no,
that was just some random bullshittery at the house.
Oh,
so that wasn't the video cause I thought it was the video and I thought that was
fucking genius.
Oh Wow.
I thought this motherfucker had the balls.
He had such confidence in the God goddamn music that the music video is going to
be a fucking cat hits this electronically and the song's coming out and the
cat's tripping out on this fucking song was what was actually,
that was,
I thought it was brilliant.
I don't think anything with maybe random radio.
I can't really remember.
Wow.
I thought that was the video and I thought you were a genius.
Well,
yes,
it is
bored,
man.
I just want to say that I think this is,
uh,
one of the first times the Internet has ever pulled people together this
quickly.
Like within 24 hours.
That's the fucking towards tweet for,
yeah.
That's how the hoard was from Omaha.
Yeah.
It's pretty bad ass,
man.
I mean,
how it happened.
I got,
I got a,
I don't know how many fucking retweets,
but I get on my computer and I just see our dead mouse,
dead miles dead mouse.
Like,
oh,
what the fuck's going on here?
And then I click on one of them.
I'm like,
oh,
he wants to do a podcast.
Oh fuck.
Yeah.
So I,
you know,
do you back and then all of a sudden Brian's on it and Brian,
sorts of the whole thing.
About three months ago I started watching because he's been on,
he goes,
you go on Ustream all the time and just like pretty much like work you,
you just talk to people and stuff.
And I was wanting it in the chat room once going,
please come on the Joe Rogan podcast,
please come.
And the next thing I know I started asking Twitter followers to help me.
So we'd just like attack your chat rooms.
Like please come on you that what got you in?
Did you get pestered by by hand?
Like a hostile takeover?
No,
I mean what got you intrigued to come here?
You don't,
you've never listened to the podcast.
Yeah,
you're right.
I've actually never listened to it.
Of course I know your work and I've seen you here and there and this and that
and shit.
You know,
I'm like thinking,
fuck man.
You know what?
Cause I've,
I've actually that everyone's
like,
oh dude,
get on the Joe Rogan thing.
Get on the Joe Rogan thing and I'm thinking,
fuck,
does this guy get it to like tear me a new asshole or I don't know.
You know what I mean?
Dude,
why do other people do other things?
People,
man,
I've,
I've heard people on people's shows,
you know,
we're,
someone will get hostile and it's,
it's real uncomfortable and it's fucking shitty.
And it's like,
I've had that happen to me before.
I was invited out to this radio show in Australia and they were like,
oh,
he's kind of a joker.
I'm like,
dude,
whatever.
I can fucking counter troll the troll,
No big deal.
He thought I'd just been fun.
I thought it'd be fun and funny.
You know what I mean?
It's like a big piss take on everything.
But Dude,
the guy was like basically,
hey,
fuck you.
You know what I mean?
It's just like,
you know,
like,
and all this shit.
Like,
Oh,
you want,
your music sucks,
so,
Hey,
what the fuck is this rumor about you?
And I'm like,
dude,
are we getting into a punchline with any of this shit?
And I,
and I ended up actually just,
well not getting like,
Ooh,
I didn't rage quit.
I just went through it.
I am I doing it.
Thanks.
Thanks for the interview later.
That's okay.
Do Ratings.
Hey,
I just
want that one little fucking snippet off you that they think is going to ruin
your career,
but it's actually going to just throw it overboard or dinosaurs,
those morons that are like making conflict up,
they're dinosaurs and not enough of those assholes.
But I mean,
I won't lie to you.
You know what I mean?
A little bit of that little shit was in the back of my head,
so I'm like,
no,
but you know what,
I'll tell you what it was.
It was,
um,
I had a chat with Carson Daly the other day and I said,
hey,
Joe Rogan,
come on.
He's like,
dude,
do it.
Do it.
You have so much fun.
And I'm like,
yeah,
you don't want,
fuck it.
Mccarson talked you into it.
Yeah.
Beautiful.
I'll give him a hug and next time I see him come in here,
right?
Yeah,
he's going to do it.
Eventually we had to reschedule it.
So I think to me,
I think I forgot when we rescheduled too,
but um,
yeah,
he's gonna come in and do the podcast and bring a show in here as well.
We're going to do his whole show from here.
He's a good dude.
Yeah,
he's really good.
Yeah.
I mean if I didn't know me,
I might think I'd be a Douche bag too.
That's all right.
I look exactly like a Douche bag.
Should look.
This is uncomfortable with me and this is going to get fucking off.
Can I go?
Uh,
to a degree.
I mean,
I'm actually friends with Dana and uh,
Jamie and Jamie.
Jamie.
Fuck.
I could ever,
ever,
no worries.
You know him.
I know.
You know,
hang on,
I got to,
what is that a video game character on the neck.
It's not a space invader.
That is a space invader.
Congratulate.
Everyone always asks me,
hey,
that's from that show or you know,
but also it's actually more the tattoos from the street artist invader.
What he did,
he went around England and did all these little tiles sets all over these
buildings.
So now I'll let you replace the tile with his own tiles that had a pattern in
enter through the gift shop.
I remember in that movie,
I never watched that movie.
Oh,
it's one of the best movies,
but it tells me that,
but it tells me it's one of those movies.
Like I was saying last night about Restrepo.
Everybody tells me I have to see it.
I have it.
I have it sitting there on the shelf.
I just,
when I'm at home,
I'm like,
let's see,
south park did this week.
You know,
I'm looking at the DVR.
I always go to silly.
I go to Anthony Bordain or fights.
That's all I really ever want to watch.
Movies are really,
it's really hard to get me to watch a movie.
Right.
You know?
But,
um,
uh,
anyway,
I just thought it was a cool thing.
It was a cool thing how it all happened.
I was excited and I'm,
I'm glad.
Glad.
Uh,
we could,
uh,
soothe your fears with me being a cunt.
How many tattoos do you actually have?
It.
You have a last time you were in la?
I think you got a tattoo and I,
I,
you're young.
You're a young Jewish man.
It's amazing.
31 I just turned 31 31.
I was going to guess less than 30,
20.
I was going to,
there's 28 that'll do,
yeah.
You're,
you're all flooded up with tattoos on a young
kind of poised to be the next to the straight up man.
I guess.
I don't know.
What is the,
a hearts on the left elbow.
Oh,
that's the legend is all there.
So let me ask you this,
man.
You're,
you're a fucking huge electronic creative music guy.
yeah.
You know,
I had no idea how big you are to be honest with you.
I had heard of you before.
I thought the logo was cool as fuck.
Like I'd seen some imagery and some electronic imagery of the,
you know,
your,
your mouse logo and shit.
I'm like,
wow,
that's like,
this is something compelling about it.
It's like an evil,
twisted,
psychedelic Mickey Mouse type thing.
I don't know,
whatever,
whatever it was.
But,
um,
then I started looking into it and I read something that you,
you guys were at the fucking Roger Center.
You guys did the Roger Center.
Yeah.
That was fucked up.
And I'm like,
oh my God.
Cause we did the UFC there and it was the biggest UFC ever.
It was 60,000 people.
I'm like you're rocking out to 60,000 fucking people.
Well we did 20 cause we just had the floor and some of the seats but like to see
that place filled with 60 must be fucking insane.
I've never seen it with 60 you know that place is so big that you know the whole
deal how it works.
But for people who don't know at home there's a hotel inside the arena and the
windows face where they play baseball.
Like it's so fucking big and this is all indoors.
You know,
cause Canada gets cold as fuck in the winter and so it's so big that you can
play baseball at guys like Jose Conseco can hit home runs inside this fucking
place and,
and not and still have room to spare and still not hit the hotel.
I mean it's insanity.
It's like a,
it's one of the most amazing constructions I've ever been inside of.
It's also the most insanely fucking impossible to rig to because of the way that
that dome is,
the retracting dome part,
those rigging points.
So if they wanted to get,
I didn't,
I didn't see the UFC show there,
but like if they wanted like lights on top of the ring,
well they can't just float.
They have to be rigged all the way the fuck up to the top of it.
And we're at the top and my dad to do it with ours cause we had a big spider
trust going across the whole thing that was only maybe about 30 feet up from the
floor but less 200 feet from the ceiling.
So it's just like this fucked up frigging,
that's a big thing with traveling artists,
right?
Like the sets that you guys bring.
That's like a big thing,
right?
Yeah.
You too apparently has some monstrous,
gigantic oh set.
That takes like a whole different picture as part of their DLA.
So they
permanently build those structures,
uh,
like they literally lay cement and then build the fucking building.
So when they get to each arena,
they do this.
Yes they have,
but they've only done it like
they have different versions of it that they can scale down or scale up.
So when they do do it at the Roger Center,
it's like a kind of a cheaper version of it,
but looks the same kind of thing.
But they had some in,
uh,
you know,
in Europe that they actually had to permanently build a structure for it.
And the structure's still fucking there and they're trying to
salame whoa.
Yeah.
It's all part of the thing,
but it's fun.
Crazy.
I don't think I'll ever go that way.
Yeah.
How did you get to be this guy?
What,
what,
what separated you from the pack when so many people making music
electronically,
you know,
it's so,
it's so a,
it's such a popular genre.
Now.
Did you start off as a DJ like,
no,
I've never spun a fucking record in my life.
So a matter of fact,
you actually don't like being called a DJ mixer?
No,
I,
I don't like that phrase.
What do you,
how can I say?
I don't like it.
It's so generalized that you kind of have to walk in and it's like,
you know,
I'm not a comedian.
I'm a fucking laugh technician.
Right,
right,
right.
What would you call it,
yourself?
I don't know.
Musician,
musician,
artist,
producer,
whatever it is,
besides being a Jujitsu master is,
um,
he is,
he's a Jujitsu master.
That's what he does.
No Shit.
Yeah.
It's how is Larry's,
but now he's like one of the top Jujitsu instructors in the world.
All right.
I'll keep my famous martial artist.
Yeah.
For Real.
I mean,
he doesn't look like he's a famous martial artists,
but uh,
besides that,
he makes a lot of music.
He's,
it makes a lot of electronic music and shit like that.
So I know like,
Hey,
you're,
you're fucking,
you're that karate guy.
I'm a musician first.
And I started Jujitsu when I was 24.
I was been producing music and Sally's 10 I got into Jujitsu just to stay in
shape and the Jujitsu blew up.
But I'm like,
I'm a fucking musician.
I'm a music.
Right,
right,
right.
That's what I do.
And the Jujitsu is a total hobby on the side and that blew up.
So you know,
so now over the last five years,
I'm trying to prove to all the people that know me through Jujitsu fail.
They think,
oh,
he's trying to do music.
They never took my music seriously.
I know people like that around the block.
Well,
there's always going to be,
hey listen,
every well it took,
I understand it because no one ever in athletics has ever made it in music.
So they're looking at me as like some famous athlete who's trying to make it in
music.
I'm like,
dude,
I've been pushing the whole time that you Jitsu was brand new and it was part
time.
So it's like a weird thing.
Yeah.
What about the Superbowl shuffle?
Are you ignoring the Superbowl shuffle?
What does he say?
No famous athletes I've ever made it in music.
What's the story?
The whole shelf.
Go bears the Superbowl show refrigerator.
Perry Shaq did an album.
I thought his album with Brian,
I think get an RMB record.
Doe He get the fuck.
Shut the fuck up.
Coby rides and not to R and B record.
Oh my God.
I would love to listen to that.
Just for the fucking pure comedy of it.
You can find Coby.
Brian,
please Google that.
I need to know that this is real.
No one need to have the Koby Bryan
professional music won't give you both.
Okay,
so how did you,
uh,
that's the problem.
The problem is like,
I've been a musician my whole life and I'm not an athlete.
I'm not an athlete.
Well,
the world says fuck you.
We don't care where.
Only one.
How did you become,
how did you get through?
What did you,
what did you,
what did you do?
I guess the way it kind of looks over the last five years,
right?
As you get fucking a lot of people thinking this is like some culminated
overnight bullshit story that's happened over the last three.
But you know,
in my mind,
and I know because I've grown up with it,
it's,
uh,
you know,
it's a,
it's a culmination of a fucking,
you know,
just 10 years of just wanting to do something,
have some predefined bullshit goals and then work towards it.
You know,
because I mean,
I really got interested in computer music when I was about 16,
17 and it was at such a time in,
in the world where computer music wasn't really feasible.
It was like,
you know,
Russell Peters comedian?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He's Canadian.
He loves you.
We all know he's on his way down.
Oh,
is he really?
He's coming.
Well,
he wants to hang out with you.
Oh,
okay.
Fuck yeah.
We want to be a part of the story of how I actually met dead mouse at a shell.
What do you prefer?
Do you prefer your actual name?
Well,
if we start fucking saying dead,
there's going to be another death rumor.
I've had three in the last four months.
Yes,
definitely.
That's what you have a Whitney Houston today.
Yeah.
I,
you know what?
I just heard about it about like three hours ago.
Who knows?
You know,
who knows?
I have no idea.
But she's 48 years old.
You got to wonder,
you know what happened.
Oh it's fairly young to just be dying.
It's very sad if it is,
if it is a cocaine thing,
if all the rumors are true,
obviously I don't,
I'm never hanging out with her.
I don't know if she's really doing coke or wasn't doing coke.
Joey Diaz told us those great stories.
Remember that?
Yeah.
Oh my God,
I tweeted that today and people got mad at me cause I tweeted that story.
Well I'm hoping,
well who's amazing artists,
but you know,
so were you into Depeche mode?
Tears for fears?
That was like the closest thing to electronic music has always been.
That's,
that's my soul.
Is that,
what were you saying about Whitney Houston?
You were kind of hoping what?
Well,
I mean I'm just kinda like morbidly hoping it's not too drug related or drug
related for that matter to know what I'm saying.
It's like a Shitty fucking Shitty,
just be an extra Shane if it was all,
well the only thing that would help,
if anything is that some may be,
it might influence some people to avoid those particular drugs.
You know,
it's,
there's no,
there's no happy ending coke stories has nobody is like,
you know,
it wasn't until I started doing coke that I really got my shit together,
you know?
I mean we always talk about,
we like,
you know,
Eddie,
you,
you and I in particular are so,
um,
we're,
we're always so positive about weed.
You don't have to use hand signals about do you want another corona?
Hey someone,
can I help you?
Can I
send you a run or sent home?
Girl don't want to eat her up.
The talking people pay a penthouse pet of the year.
That's how strong this place is.
You just got over yard it.
I'll give you that award here.
Give this to the bartender.
Dang.
Just go and just go get a a bunch of beers.
He was thinking too,
I was totally thinking right before.
You sound like there's no beer.
You know what?
We can't go to the bar.
So it's the rest of the show with no more beer that's going to get by.
You know why he was thinking that?
Cause he's the Indians out.
Less than three corona come out tonight.
No,
I'd have to have like four or five shots come on to the Indians.
The Indians here right now.
He's here right now,
bro.
He's sharpening his Tomahawk with a,
with a file.
Are we on the air?
No,
definitely not.
Definitely no.
We're on the air man.
Oh Shit.
Oh yeah.
We're not going anywhere.
So bring us back to it.
So you uh,
you tears for fears?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
You know what?
My Dad tried music since he went to Columbia House.
Thank God they're not fucking around too much now these days because they'd be
the first on dibs.
But with the whole Columbia House deal and as you know,
my dad got this new Luckman CD player cutting edge fucking technology at the
time and he bought into that,
um,
you know,
get x CDs for a penny.
Shit.
How did they ever make any money?
Exactly right?
Well,
they must've made it least fucking 100 cents.
Something.
Must've had a pain.
It's totally forgot about that.
Never came up on there.
I did it.
I did it twice with cassettes,
cds for a penny.
I don't think I ever got to the CDS.
I think I want to do something ridiculous like that and they send them to you
and you nor him and you don't send them back yo money or something.
Yeah,
that actually was part of it.
That's how they afford it.
She was completely ridiculous names.
You just put any name,
your address,
any name that me.
Do you remember that?
However,
pastors marketing strategy we're going to give you,
at the time,
they were fucking cds for 99 cents.
How do you split that with the bands?
All this shit?
What was it?
Just like extra stock.
I mean what it was that there's,
what is the re having more foreigner albums were distributed that way.
Then anything
foreigner and journey,
those fucking journey cassettes just flew out door.
That was the first thing that people picked on the list that was working in a
record store.
Right when cds were coming in and like cassettes were like going down.
We still had records because record stores.
That's what,
Oh did you just get all,
all this?
I'll have a chronic coronas are cool.
Thank you,
sir.
Here.
So anyway,
so you started creating music and how did you get,
I mean you,
you obviously there's been some sort of a massive leap somewhere along the line
that you've gotten to be this guy who could fucking sell the Rogers Center.
That's incredible,
man.
It took a while.
You know it
like,
you know,
four years,
four years.
I know I of that.
That's crazy.
How did that happen?
Fucking say that's a wild man.
That's crazy.
You know what I mean?
People are screaming at their,
their,
their computer right now a while to go from four years of creating music to all
of a sudden be selling off the Roger Center.
That's amazing.
That is really cool.
Staggering.
You know,
like it's just,
I guess I'm super lucky to be in this climate of the development of what I'm
trying to get at is how do you think you hit this resonance?
I mean,
what you're doing is,
is really like funky electronic shit,
but you obviously have hit a residence that people are really drawn to.
It's not simply,
you know,
you've been in the business,
he got lucky.
You've stumbled in,
no.
Did they,
there's people that love the sounds you're creating.
Yeah.
Okay.
I mean there's definitely a music element in that.
Of course,
you know,
I ate,
my parents put me in like piano boot camp after school.
So between the time hours of like three and when they got off of work,
I was classically trained the whole time.
Wow.
That's like,
but,
but I forgot all that shit when I was 16 because computers kind of came out and
then,
you know,
fuck a piano.
Right?
Yeah.
Uh,
but,
but fuck me.
Did that ever come in handy later?
I'm sure.
You know,
cause you just work out melodies,
countermelody melodies,
all that stuff requires a certain amount of intelligence.
It's not just fucking know how to float that mouse,
that mouse heads a good move to.
Dude,
I'll tell you what,
the listening to you because of the mouse head makes me feel cooler.
When I was,
I was watching some youtube clips and you were on stage and you had the mouse
head on and you were rocking out and the crowd was rocking out and I was like,
do something dope about that.
There's something I liked the fact that this fucking guy's wearing a crazy giant
mouse head.
He was actually a big influence on my idea for the logo because I've always
recognized him as his mouse head and so then I was like,
dude,
he you,
you are a master almost of marketing because you know the,
the idea of the mouse.
I did do a lot of that was Disney night.
You know the Dick off.
Well No,
me and Disney are cool now.
You're cool.
Yeah.
Actually it was really funny.
We had to play a show in Anaheim once at a this at the thing and they were like,
dude,
you know Disney called and they want you to come play a dude.
I'm thinking I get to be led into this like fucking dark.
Mickey and goofy are going to come out with some cool shit on me or Joel.
Nope.
Disney has never had an issue with it at all.
No,
we're,
we're totally cool because it is a different shape.
It is a different shape,
but since I'm a math thing and I'm not and they're not really,
well I guess the today that
are in the music business and stuff like that,
but it's so distinguishable between the two identities that they're just like,
yeah,
that's cool.
I'm wondering at the same time too,
because when I did file for a design patents on my logo and stuff like that,
it's like one of the first things I had to do was go to different countries and
apply for logo copyrights and stuff like that.
Right now,
Disney must have a crack fucking team of experts of people doing this shit
because I'll tell you,
I used to work for a software company in Belgium that used to have a,
uh,
a studio software and it was called fruity loops.
One of my favorites.
Kellogg's put a fucking cease and desist serious on the name.
And,
and dude,
we're talking cereal and music application.
Nothing to do with each other,
but for whatever reason,
you know,
they gave in to the machine and said,
we're going to have to rename this studio.
But everyone still calls it if they own the name,
they don't want you using it for anything.
I can understand what the true like mouse it,
danger mouse,
a dead mouse,
fucking mighty mouse.
Everyone's animal.
You get,
you don't get to,
I'm lying.
I'm the only lawyer.
You know,
you don't get to own that.
That's silly.
There's true.
But so the actual,
the similarities of the,
you know,
the circle in this thing,
I thought that was a little close.
So I kind of thought that maybe someone was asleep at the wheel when we had,
when that had gone through,
because basically it was one day,
it was a call from my lawyer saying,
dude,
you got the patent.
You're,
you're good.
Wow.
Virtually untouchable right now.
And I'm like,
oh,
thank God there's so baller.
They don't give a fuck Disney.
They're just,
the executives are sitting around and gold underwear laying on stacks of cash.
That bitch have his fucking logo,
whatever.
Who gives a shit me back so much.
Disney are suing other departments of disease for real.
Well,
I'm sure,
do you know this for fact lie down,
but I,
to be really careful,
selection happens,
you know what I mean?
So it probably doesn't happen.
I'm going to go out on a limb and say it doesn't have a,
Disney was actually where I got my very first development deal.
I did a Sitcom for Disney and now and then I'll just shut the fuck up.
Then they were very nice,
you know?
And I was a dirty comedian man that was fucking terrible dirty comedian.
And they gave me a development deal.
They were pretty cool.
They did.
They're a lot more open minded than you would think.
You know,
they're essentially just in entertainment company,
but the name Disney,
like you automatically associate everything with like super family values type
Shit,
you know?
Yeah,
right.
I was up to Jonas brothers and all that.
That's just smart business.
You know,
like there's,
there's a lot of money and that babysitting money.
It's a fucking a lot of money man.
You know,
it's out there.
Like Bill Hicks used to talk about with the,
you know,
I remember when um,
Tiffany and Debbie Gibson where all the shit,
that's when Bill Hicks was a alive and he,
I have all these jokes about Tiffany and Debbie Gibson and how ridiculous it
was.
But the bottom line is somebody likes that man.
Somebody likes that.
There's babysitting money out there.
You know?
When
you met me at Modo,
how one,
how did you,
where did you meet him?
I think it was the only guy
that was able to spot him out,
walk by because that's the game designer or a super Mario brothers,
all that stuff.
And like were,
where are you?
Whoa.
Hey.
Wow.
Where were you at when that happened?
I was actually in my trailer.
We um,
he was,
he was not to be announced.
This is last name me a Moto Moto his last name?
Yeah,
it should guru or a Shogi Japanese.
Yeah.
Um,
if you were,
if your name was like Miyamoto Musashi,
if that was your name,
you would say Musashi Miyamoto,
right?
You would say I,
I believe so.
What's going on there?
Brian being assaulted.
Your mind was totally done.
Oh,
there you go.
Um,
so he has another aim is that the Musashi's is last
Miyamoto's his last name Shigeru is his first name.
Miyamoto.
She grew up,
cause you,
even in your live shows you incorporate like,
like,
like your,
your logo inside,
like video games and stuff like on your led wall.
Right.
I've seen that before.
So,
uh,
did,
did he know who you were?
Did you don't know?
But he,
he's,
he's very Japanese.
He had a translator with them and all that.
So it was actually kind of funny when I talked to him,
obviously I told him I was big fan and he was like,
oh,
okay.
And then you know,
I've got this ghost,
the Bu Tattoo on sign your arm.
Yeah,
he did.
He signed my arm and now you tattooed immediately called up peewee on sunset.
And I'm like,
Bro,
I got a tattoo.
This
that's uh,
yeah.
I've seen a few people have a other people's names tattooed on their arms.
Mark Marin recently did that.
Some guy had marked sign his arm they had tattooed on that's gotta to be a trip.
Well,
I've done that for a lot of fans too.
You know,
it only seems right.
You know what I mean?
Because you're thinking for a while I'm like,
man,
this kid's crazy.
And you're like,
he's like,
so my arms,
I'm hiring you going to get this,
I'm going to get this tattooed and I signed this arm and then Lo and behold,
I see them at a future gigs.
I did memory something.
I'm fucking got a tattooed.
I'm like,
dude,
that's nuts.
That happens with kiss a lot.
I have a tee shirt.
Shit,
I have a tee shirt company.
It's called higher prime mate.
It was one of them,
a little wearing.
It's all mostly just monkeys and weeds and monkeys and psychedelics,
monkeys,
DMT,
monkeys and mushrooms.
But a lot of people have taken the images and turn them into tattoos and it's
crazy.
I,
I've collected a bunch of images,
but it's,
it's really a trip to me and they're like,
these teachers that I'm sounding like,
one dude has the whole back of his neck is this psychedelic monkey.
A monkey in the Lotus position is third eyes glowing and it's like,
it's pretty fucking bad ass.
He's sitting on the DMT molecule in a,
in a inside of a lotus flower and this guy's got it tattooed on his neck.
I'm like,
well this is kind of crazy.
And that thing that the Brian's logo,
the death squad logo,
but it's actually changed.
The new one is different.
So unfortunately for those people that got it,
that one who was telling me about this on the way and change it,
I don't like the change that the new one's sucks.
I'm going to be honest with you.
This one's the shit I liked.
I don't like the main,
the chaplain
chaplain,
but I do like the fact that he strapped the other way.
The new guy,
it's like a,
it's like he's,
you know,
a bunny from planet
Bunnings please.
I love bunnies.
Delicious.
You must have it.
You don't even fight with mashed potatoes,
you know,
fuck you up.
You were saying that like millions of people have your tattoo and it has to be
true is,
I even thought about it definitely in the hundreds of thousands or hundreds of
twos actually even thought about getting your logo.
I have the first,
why don't you get us the first?
Wow.
That's the first issue that,
oh wow.
And what is on the right hand side of the mouse?
Actually,
I'll tell you a funny story.
It's a,
it's a UPC barcode because I was working with a software company at the time and
they did a barcode measurement system kind of thing,
and I thought,
wow,
I wonder if you could actually scan a barcode that if it was like tattooed on
you and then it,
it didn't work.
Oh,
well myth myth.
Fucking busted.
Yeah,
there you go.
Did you,
you started off doing web design,
right?
Yeah.
I also did it.
I hated it.
Did you,
did you enjoy it?
I enjoyed it when it was cool and fun and I had a really client and he's like,
yeah,
that's Rad.
But I hated it when he,
it's,
it's a little too blue.
Maybe we can add some brain was like,
dude,
well I'm the fucking designer.
Right?
So how about I designed the fucking thing?
Well,
if you've got all the ideas in your head and you know how to do it,
then what the fuck do you need me?
If you had a client,
one client came to you and said,
Bro,
if you had a client and the client came to you and said,
hey,
you know,
have a dairy farm,
we're trying to build a website and you're like,
all right,
I'm going to do it my way,
bitch.
Well my way in because they're going to kind of cool.
You work with a customer to agree,
but some of the customers are just like,
some of the clients are just like,
dude,
you're doing this wrong.
And uh,
and I think that the balance of the way that this load understand what you're
saying right.
Then why don't you do it?
Yeah.
You have to have a certain amount of artistic license to do anything that you
don't actually go to them.
That's also one of the reasons why you're probably so great at your music is
that you know,
you have a very specific vision and you're,
you're really enchanted by that vision.
You want to follow it.
One thing about being a producer of electronic music because electronic music is
had this stigma for like,
you know,
a good decade and a half of,
basically people taking other people's music and,
and then,
you know,
working in all these justifications as to why it's an art form.
Okay.
Yes.
Turntablism in itself,
definitely a fucking art form.
You know,
it's like look at the fucking key berets,
you know,
and all that shit and just going fucking crazy with that.
That's fine.
But you don't say,
can you do it?
Can I do it?
I can't do it.
Well there's gotta be an art form and no,
it's gotta be,
you can't tell me that there's not as,
I think carpentry is an art form.
Absolutely.
Everything is,
you know,
everything with focus in a tent and you use your creativity.
But you know,
since you know the term Dj,
you know it was coined and then people started getting like kind of lazy with it
to the point well with electronic music to where you could just play the hit big
track and then just fade out that last 30 seconds and then fade in the first 30
seconds of the other one done.
That's to me that's not very archetypal and,
and it's not you and you're not adding any unique element into it.
So to have the kind of control where your making the music that allows you to do
that and in different ways,
you know what I mean?
That's what makes it special and unique to that one guy as opposed to unique to
that one group of fucking guys,
you know?
And,
and it was getting really stagnant and there was DJ,
this,
Dj,
that Dj stage of that when it was all down to the playlist at the end of the
day.
And none of those guys had any of their own shit in there that made it unique to
them.
Just a part of the natural evolution of music.
And that sort of had to happen before everybody went,
hey,
you know what man,
you guys are just copying what the Ibv your own man styles.
Right?
And you got a guy
fucking log and he's going down on the fucking log.
And Aaron was like,
yeah,
right.
And then this other dude was like,
yeah,
we'll fucking check this out.
He takes a fucking log,
does the exact same thing,
you know what I mean?
It's just not,
and then he's like debunking the other fucking dude,
right.
It escalating it.
[inaudible] so the,
the,
like the people would criticize you,
all you're doing is playing other people's shit.
And then people go,
okay,
well I'm going to make my own shit.
Is that what happened?
I think that's what happened.
Yeah.
And it had to happen because,
you know,
it was a,
to legitimize the music well to both that
and,
and make things unique for that.
We're like,
you know,
associated with that one person as opposed to something that was this group of
people that you weren't quite sure who was doing what and which Dj was better
than the other one.
I loved the fact that you can just make all these noises just on your computer
now.
I mean,
I know you might not be able to do what you do,
but Brian's made some crazy shit just with garageband.
Yeah,
absolutely.
This whole last album was done completely in garage bands and they are huge.
What is it?
Justice,
justice,
justice.
Really.
I'm an old blow out of their old,
well I listened to like Greg Allman.
What?
They're a little dirtier,
a little grungy,
sounding the my stuff and listened to Leonard Skinner.
Fucking,
their shit is awesome and it's so low fi low tech,
no million dollar studio bullshit.
You like bands like the black keys?
I love him.
I love,
actually I worked with them.
Fucking cats mailing.
Is it freak?
Sorry.
I work with them.
Where'd you work with them?
Oh,
we did the VGA or sorry,
the Vmax.
Oh wait,
wow.
Fuck did we do,
oh my God.
Really?
You Sleeping?
My managers fucking asleep.
Earning 1%.
Whoa.
Hold on.
24 real.
Talk to me about that bullshit.
Go shake Dina.
Huh?
Never supposed to play tomorrow.
There's my one.
I haven't even heard of getting more than 15.
It's okay.
He's here and said he said he's tired because he was working so fucking hard to
ask grammys.
Oh my goodness.
Are you nominated for anything?
Yeah,
three,
three of them.
Wow.
Don't ask me what they are please.
Oh No,
fuck man.
It's kind of cool.
Dot.
Best dance.
So I believe in God.
I got to VH one best.
So anyway,
I'm mug you you're making me lose shit.
The black keys blip.
Blackie's dude,
it was amazing.
We a oh
the vmax.
Yes.
The video music awards.
Which MTV?
Yes.
Yeah.
And um,
we kind of,
I was kind of charged with the task of being like the house music guy,
like,
you know,
throughout the whole night.
So like,
Hey,
and the commercial break,
here's this guy in a mouse had,
okay,
here's a commercial vms you did to virgin mobile fest.
Vma,
virgin music or fuck video music awards.
It should be the MBA's music video awards.
Right.
Somebody,
somebody was probably the video music awards.
I had to work with all these other artists like Robin and I'm at Jason Derulo,
the black keys and someone else.
But um,
anyway,
the point was is I had to kind of take their stuff and electronic eyes it and
remix it in a way that,
you know,
they could either perform with and play with and all that stuff.
And I did,
uh,
I did that song,
that really good song by the black keys.
Got To get another one.
An older one.
No,
it's an older one.
It was,
it was their big hit.
Ah,
Geez.
Joe Loves,
I love the book.
You love him,
but you can't love them.
Go.
What,
what um,
what song you can be thinking about.
So many songs tighten up.
Thank you.
Yes,
it was definitely tighten up and it was really cool.
So I did this kind of cool version of it and it,
you know,
and then play that out during the commercial break and,
and,
and they were into it and they were like,
dude,
yeah,
we should probably,
you know,
like make this an unofficial remix or something like that.
And I'm just like,
Oh man,
that'd be awesome.
But I got to work on so much shit that it just,
we never got around to it.
Oh,
that's too bad.
Yeah.
People's tastes in music is so bizarre.
I put on a,
well,
I asked Brian to put on little black submarines last night while we were doing
our ice house chronical show.
And I'm like,
this is one of my favorite songs when I love this fucking song.
And I expected a lot of people and most people on Twitter,
ironically,
we're there,
we're in agreement.
Like,
wow,
what a great fucking song.
But on my message board,
my message board is filled with so many hunts.
He says,
close down,
couldn't farm
fucking cunt.
It's a cunt farm.
These guys were shitting on this song.
It's nothing.
It makes me think of stairway to heaven.
Shut your fucking dumb,
whole dumb negative twat face fuck head.
It's a great God damn song for you to just get on negative like that.
I guarantee your life is a bag of shit about music.
It's pretty subjective but it's not like nothing is that song as brilliant man.
It's brilliant and I'm just kidding.
Obviously you're allowed to hate it.
Obviously.
I'm only fucking around people like Kim,
man,
we fucking dictate what I like.
A lot of this passion is just for entertainment.
Okay.
I don't really want you to,
people get so serious.
Like we were talking about Margaret Thatcher the other day and I'm like women
shouldn't be allowed to run anything.
Half of that I'm joking around for fun,
right?
Like it's so many women that got mad at me.
Like really?
I'm like,
do you not know any men do not know what happens when five guys get together and
drink and smoke pot.
They started talking shit and when one guy starts talking,
how awesome Margaret Thatcher is the every other dude,
the rooms of Margaret Thatcher,
she could suck my deck.
That's all you start thinking.
That's how the guys react that like what's the only reason why she was running
shit is cause all those English guys just,
you know,
none of them could fucker.
Well they'll let her,
you know,
we're making things up.
We don't really believe anything we're saying.
We're just trying to be funny.
I'm sure Margaret Thatcher was awesome by the way.
Meryl Streep,
Wonderful Actress.
I was only joking around,
I said she sucked,
but she can't.
I like damaged.
No,
it's arguing with people.
Now this is my point.
I have a point.
It's arguing with people on the Internet.
You know,
it's like people's tastes.
The Internet.
Because when we started putting that,
you're going to be on 99% of the people were super site.
What was the 1%?
There's 1% cut face.
Shithead,
loser,
negative.
You got to get back to that one fucking guy.
Cause he's the guy that's the first in line that starts the ball of negativity.
So here's the thing is easy read.
You've got to give it up.
There's a science.
Well yeah and no.
Okay.
But there's,
there's a science behind all of this.
Fucking trolling.
There really is.
So you go look at a youtube video and if a top rated or most recent common is
something negative,
people tend to agree with that whether they believe it or not.
Yes.
You know what I mean?
Fuck this.
Yeah.
You don't want you right.
Fuck this and yeah,
those other two dudes are right.
Fuck him.
Right?
Yeah,
no,
I enjoy that.
I enjoy the one completely out to left field,
super negative.
You know,
in a world full of happiness and it's well crafted as long as it's handmade.
It's just some,
yeah,
we'll fucking very rarely,
one of my favorite guys is a daft punk and their film interstellar,
I must watch at least once a month.
Do you ever have any plans to like maybe released like a full length movie using
your music and maybe animation using her logo or something?
Well that's a,
that's a project among projects,
right?
You did that.
Then maybe Disney might want to read again.
Seriously.
If you were making your own animation with the mouse,
I think that was actually up there in that whole like a pot of names to do the
tron thing.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I thought I was music soundtrack,
what to do.
Right.
But honestly if it was me and I knew they were in there,
I'd have to give it to them.
I enjoyed that music
man.
A little bit of it was geekness Dahlia for my,
I enjoyed the first movie and I was like looking forward to it,
but it was also just just for the sheer cinematic,
this,
the,
the does the visuals of it all the world they created.
I give it to you.
It doesn't have to be a perfect story.
You're doing a lot,
you know you're getting a lot of shit done here.
You creating this crazy artificial world where people ride motorcycles and chop
each other in half.
Anyway,
I'll let,
I'll let you slide try.
Yeah,
you got to trial a little mouse.
But I love it and it was kinda interesting how they're not quite ready to do
human faces.
You know the William,
what is his name?
William hurt.
William hurt's character.
Pretty close,
but it was a little creepy.
I haven't watched orange in a really better it.
I don't want to ruin the
DTV.
Marginally better than I am legend.
When the lion comes out.
Remember when the lion comes out and I am legend.
What happened?
It looks terrible.
It it ruined the whole movie for me.
This line looks so stupid.
It was fun.
It looks like a lion from Dora the explorer.
It was like did it to Dora.
Dora the explorer lion comes out of the bushes.
It was ridiculous.
It was terrible.
Cgi.
They can't do animals that are real yet.
They can do dinosaurs.
They can do alien,
they can do all sorts of shit that doesn't exist.
That's true.
Good with old man.
They're not bad.
They're not bad cause there's a lot of wrinkles.
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
It's not real.
Pretty close to when they can't get that.
They're pretty close.
So I agree with you.
The hardest one.
Discussing the hot chick.
You could deal with a real rough texture with the old man.
What they can't do though.
They can't do animals yet.
They can't do like a dog.
So yeah,
it's a first the face,
it looks fake.
Definitely the head of my department for its real issue,
it doesn't look good.
I'm about to
embark on a serious CG Durney that I can't really give too much information
about.
But we were actually like been bidding around with companies right now and dude,
we're looking at like 500 grand a minute.
Yeah,
it's going to make 500 grand.
I'm no,
no,
that's cost to do like [inaudible] it's about,
oh no,
no,
but we're talking like a final rendered all my posts and everything.
It's insane.
So first,
so expensive for 90 minute movies.
What is that $45 million?
Well No,
I mean if you want to inject it into a scene to Cambodia,
he just needed a car.
[inaudible] if that's entirely CG,
if it's entirely CG like final fantasy,
the cheaper,
but if you are doing camera tracking with real world stuff,
then that's when it gets expensive.
$500,000 a minute.
I'm a fucking minute.
So real,
it isn't really is $45 million for a 90 minute movie.
Not if it's all CG and it's not like shit,
like transformers is not going to cost 500 movie like final fantasy.
No,
because it's all CG.
It increase incorporates no real
shit issue when you incorporate real world,
right?
Yes.
Because you have to do camera tracking and obviously shit makes sense.
Yeah.
Dan,
he's very knowledgeable with all this.
I had a two hour long meeting about it today.
It's $1 million a day.
Fuck it jammy.
They sometimes do it with music videos,
so what they do is they'll
that minute and they'll split it over the whole video of like if it's seven
minute long video,
it's not,
it's not going to be six minutes of this and then Oh,
last minutes all with CGI.
They cut it in the edit.
It
so hard to wrap your head around.
That's when you just need to date a artists.
That's all you said.
It just,
you know
Brian Brian Solution for everything I know about fucking 30 artery single,
very nerdy fucking talented.
We can whip that shit up.
Date every one week.
You date a shadower,
one week data.
Fucking motion.
Jesus,
your life is going to be a graveyard as his,
can I tell him my dead mouse?
Blow it up.
Store.
I want to blow what?
This is my,
this is my story.
I don't know maybe.
Wow.
Cool story Bro.
Shut down son.
This is based on the merit of your previous stories.
He doesn't even know you.
I'm going to blow your music up right now,
so that's not what he needs at this point.
His career.
Are you going to redeem herself from the previous day?
This is what happened to him.
He's here.
We're doing a podcast shit,
dead mouse story like might as well tell the story.
Okay,
so about a year and a half ago,
he does a big thing at the staple center with a bunch of other Djs,
like a big gaming convention.
Eat three big things.
Staple,
set,
huge.
Danny Loner dude is producing my stuff.
Exelon snails.
He has tickets.
He calls me up.
You want to go?
I go,
cool.
We go last minute.
It shows huge.
It's massive.
It's amazing.
I really didn't get to hear too much music.
I W W W really wasn't paying attention at this point.
I didn't hear,
I didn't know any dead mouse stuff.
I didn't know.
And uh,
we went backstage,
you know,
took some pictures.
I met him briefly.
I remember the tattoo now when I see him.
So,
um,
six months goes by,
I'm getting,
I'm getting tattoo.
Um,
get an ink done and dude,
who's tattooed on me,
he's got Pandora dubstep going on and I'm sitting there for like five hours
listening to and I don't like anything mad.
It's very hard for me to be excited about music,
man.
You gotta be fucking good.
The whole day goes by and one song crushes me.
Bassnectar tea time stretch.
I heard that shit.
I was getting on my fork time stretch by Bassnectar is amazing.
It blew me away.
So we had to stop tattoo and how to write that shit down.
I'm like,
rarely do I get blown away like that.
Most of that shit was just like good production.
But I'm like,
where's the song I'm looking for this.
I need to hear that.
Throw that shit.
Oh,
it's amazing.
It's an actor Bassnectar time stretch.
One of the most amazing songs and it's in the dead mouse.
Eric.
Uh,
Eric,
but let me finish my story.
I like how this story,
no,
hold on.
That's not your shit.
Super talented.
Okay.
So the whole day there's one song Bassnectar times.
So then I get into my car and my arms all wrapped up and I go,
I got one awesome song by just listening to,
you know,
listening to a Pandora dubstep station.
So right there on way home as I'm take about an hour and a half to get home with
traffic,
I put on dubs,
I want to find another song.
So I kept listening song after song after song,
an hour into it and then boom,
ghosts and stuff come up,
comes on.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Not too close and stuff goes to the stuff.
I heard that,
I heard that shit and no serious.
This is a real story.
Bam.
Bought it on iTunes right away.
No Way.
This is a real story.
This is like a make believe story.
Look,
you're in a castle.
Yeah.
Yes,
exactly.
I don't know what that means,
but that's the way it went down.
I wasn't,
I didn't like anything the whole day.
The whole day of listening in Dubstep Bassnectar time stretch and your ghosts
and stuff.
That fucking floored me.
I bought it on iTunes.
I don't bike shit unless it's fucking living here.
Some volume,
Brian.
That's some real shit right there.
He's looking at me like,
do you want to do it?
Pushed the fader Ravi.
He's scared.
It'd be like cooking in front of Anthony Bordain.
I'm not sure what mix this is.
I don't know if this is the same,
that loud.
It's the original.
This one.
Well,
no,
it's the original.
This is the original.
Oh,
this is cool.
No,
I don't get tired of this fucking one.
What do you,
uh,
what do you,
what do you get?
Free Bird,
man.
For me,
this is all unique.
All right.
I Apologize,
but I'm enjoying it.
Um,
how are you creating this?
What did you use?
This one is the only one track
I didn't do in the studio.
I didn't and a hotel room in uh,
England.
Oh yeah.
It was really funny.
And My name came up.
Yeah.
Just chilling out and I got some computers and stuff.
And there's that baseline again.
That's your fault.
That's the government
dangerous.
I'm messing about.
And I'm talking to a,
he's,
he's a big Dj over in England.
Pete Tong,
uh,
he does the BBC radio one show and all that stuff.
And uh,
we,
we had some discussion about the hotel that I was staying in.
He's like,
yeah,
Bro,
it's haunted.
Uh,
you know,
in doors are opening and shutting and my room and shit.
And I got,
so,
you know,
and I'm just kinda like,
I named songs at like spur of the moment kind of bullshit thing.
I don't,
I don't really put any thought into the name,
so I just called it ghost and shit.
So I sent it off.
Yeah.
And then we send it off to emi and they're like,
oh,
we can't call it ghosting.
Shit goes and stuff.
Alright.
Whatever.
Most of the stuff.
That's kind of cool because you know what?
No,
cause if you,
even if you did that,
you would have to put that goddamn sticker on the front of the CD,
that explicit lyrics,
even though it's not a lyric in the song title,
and then that actually detriment you from fucking
millions.
Yeah.
I was
trying to find na's life we chose,
there's so much cussing in it.
All my God,
they said,
he says the n word like without the chorus it's huge,
but on iTunes I keep downloading the clean one.
There's just,
they just pull out the lyrics.
I'm like,
Bach really
sucks.
Without all that shit,
there's nothing more disturbing.
When you're in a club and you're looking to have a good time and you realize a
song that you're hearing is a censored version of it.
Oh,
I remember a few of those that the track didn't work that one or get you forget.
You
forget you.
It's terrible.
Good with the fuck you.
I realize,
I thought it was a great song all the way through,
but then when they change due date,
this is real because I might have blocked it out and they call the people and
slugging to watch that a son of a bitch
fellows or something like that.
Over dub was the girl that Brad Pitt used to be married to.
She's an now the other one,
Angelina Jolie,
the first one.
No,
the first one,
man,
when it's
boom.
Naacos Gwenyth Paltrow,
uh,
isn't that show glee?
Right.
And she was singing,
forget you.
She was singing it.
I'm pretty sure I heard it.
I might've just fury of SOC.
I might've just blacked out.
It was just too much irony for me.
I couldn't handle it.
I did.
I wanted to be a part of my imagination,
so I couldn't even talk about it on stage fruit kit.
You forget the song.
She was singing it and I'm pretty sure she was saying it.
It was,
it was death.
It was death.
But it made me so sad that that,
that first song was so dope.
We played that song on the podcast.
Never as a song gone from being so fucking bad ass to just some shit that's like
Muzak elevator that you don't even want to hear man hate that song.
Fuck you song was the shit when it first came out of fucking ugly fat guy.
Second Fuck you.
Fuck you.
And you're like,
Yay.
You wanted him to say it?
Yeah.
Say it dude.
I wonder if you had to pull back on like certain shows and do the forget you.
Of course he does.
Really?
Probably all he does now.
They probably made a deal with them.
You know they probably bring him new white women on a regular basis and all he
had the next rage against the machine on the Christmas special.
I'd fucking BBC where they going to go?
Okay,
well you can't say fuck you.
I won't do what you tell me baby.
You I won't do what you tell me.
You won't do what you do.
They really say that.
Did you just think of this right now?
Cause that was awesome.
It is awesome.
Forget you.
I won't.
Do you remember when the Beatles got on the Ed?
So,
or excuse me,
the has got on the edge,
couldn't get much higher risks.
Gabe,
you couldn't get much higher.
Yeah,
that was a big deal.
They wanted them to change those lyrics out and it said it couldn't get much.
Forget you.
And he did it.
He like in,
in the movie you got like real close to the camera when he said it and they
fucking violated them.
Yesterday I was singing it on camera.
I was singing the second
verse two,
uh,
we,
she swallowed it old Nwa.
[inaudible]
sing it.
The lip.
Sorry.
You could easily be one or two.
You could be a standing up,
forget you.
Nonstop tagging.
So I was singing along to the second verse and it was a lot,
you know,
there was some people around and I would just sing and there was a Lotta,
a Lotta n word in there and you were singing it and there were black people in
the car when the hall,
no,
but it did feel wrong.
It fell uncomfortable.
And I you singing that song?
That sounded good.
I love that song.
You really,
she swallowed it.
That's one of the songs and seriously is one of the greatest.
It was like it was pretty cool when I was 15 yeah,
exactly.
When I went in to hear people.
Yeah.
My,
I remember listening to it the first time I ever listened to that,
sorry.
I was on a treadmill in revere Massachusetts.
I was at the gym.
That's funny that you remember exactly what you doing and where that spot to
absolutely remembered because I had just recently got,
was a dope ass Walkman cassette player at the time it was,
it was the shit.
It was bright yellow.
Okay.
And I was doing my cardio on this fucking treadmill and I'm on this treadmill
and I remember listening to Nwa while I'm chatting him.
Oh man,
she's fucking guys.
You're seeing some really crazy shit.
You know
all this is all about being violent against white people.
Like I'm like,
what am I supposed to be entertained by this?
I was so confused,
but I was like,
what is this?
Come on there.
They're getting there.
They're criminals.
That's a good thing.
All of a sudden I remembered like,
Yo,
what the fuck is going on?
I remember I can't be this guy because I'm only 20 I can't be this guy.
He's going,
what the fuck is going on with this country country?
Not yet.
It was to gain,
but yet those were the thoughts that were happening in my mind as I was
listening to this CD,
that one I listened to LM Fao,
I do.
You don't like that sexy song.
I'll tell you what.
I didn't like that sexy song until I saw the video and I thought that's a fun.
Do you remember me saying I was in Vegas and I heard this stupid loop of hurting
them like seven songs.
He had a bit about that,
a bit about how much I hated that and then I found out it was an elm.
Fao had that in like one of their main songs.
That was Afrojack that started that whole thing.
It was not them,
right originally.
Right,
right.
Okay.
Yeah,
but that happened in music that happens in,
especially in new,
see electronic music goes through these phases.
K The first like notable phase was the Benny Benassi baseline.
Okay.
Bentley,
there's big farty anyone saw wave right now?
What does that mean?
Who's Benny?
Benny Benassi.
He's a lovely guy from Italy.
Awesome.
Dj Producer.
He did the track,
you know,
I uh,
satisfaction.
Have you ever heard that dancy track?
I can't get my satisfaction is like a rolling stones cover.
No,
no,
no.
It wasn't a cover.
It was a complete original and was like this robotic voices anyway,
breakout fucking track.
But it had the signature sound.
Now it's nothing new.
It wasn't this amazing breakout technology,
but it's like this just big thick meaty fuck off like a saw tooth wave that you
hear.
And,
and,
and he kind of like capitalized on that.
And that was a thing,
you know,
for a while.
So a lot of other producers started fucking knocking it off.
And then what happened was,
you know,
you had guys like Josh winks who kind of pioneered the uh,
the TB three Oh three.
Now this is like some old,
you know,
Japanese baseline instrument that was supposed to be used as a base simulator.
And then buddy got the idea to crank the resonance on it and then,
uh,
you know,
use it as a sin.
So it did this doot Doo Dee Dee Dee Dee,
do you know,
you know,
they're like the fucking three or three.
Then everyone started doing right.
So we were like the electronic music committee or committee group,
you know,
we're all susceptible to these kinds of fads.
That happens.
So now that's some good music history right there though right now.
Dip Low does this thing.
He comes out with taking like a piece of vocal and taking just the little
sustain little bit of it and go in that era and then everyone starts fucking
doing it.
Yeah.
So there's all of these little fads that just keep happening.
Music.
Yeah.
I like that.
That's a constant.
I can't fucking stand it.
I hate it.
I hate it when there are narratives because then the tracks put your hands up.
I'll fucking robbery.
Tell me what the fucking dude I've robbery.
It's fun.
I actually liked that shit.
When they really
love the song comes to this massive crescendo,
then
a massive baseline happens.
It's like,
it's like a bad fucking porn is what it is.
I'm coming,
I'm coming.
Well no fucking shit.
The door,
I'm coming,
I'm coming all over you.
I'm coming all over.
You know we get it.
Those random voices,
he feels like he can't stand watching porn with narratives.
It's like,
oh you're fucking me.
Fucking you.
I'm fucking you.
And then it's like if you ever seen spinal tap,
have you seen spinal tap movie rd puff game.
That's right.
That's the only thing that comes to mind when I hear these.
Like you know,
obligatory Saifai samples in dance music.
You know high already Popkin my records.
I already fucking Pauli America already fucking Pauline records already.
Pumpkin polyamory records and then his name comes up on the screen and says
already fucking Pauline my records.
I'm like,
dude,
that is amazing.
I don't know if they meant to do that or not,
but it's just so fucking funny cause he said it like about 15 times taught it
and then the show his name like in case you didn't fucking get it,
that's fine.
That's so they do it in
porn and they do it in dance music and they can could ruin porn.
Oh,
it totally can they,
cause it's like [inaudible] this guy and he's like,
Yo,
you're sucking my dick.
No Shit.
Do they have to fucking do this for people that might not understand what's
happening online?
People,
well,
so I didn't think about people masturbating to books on tape.
Well,
why wouldn't you want to just a salary as the book?
Do you know there's,
there's websites where that narrate a porn videos just for nine people.
It's just like he's approaching,
coming outside,
pulling down his pants,
his caucus philosophy.
Uh,
he's got a big helmet,
verbal and it's seriously good.
Or they're really descriptive.
Like proletics.
Yeah,
it's weird because it's a
here
man.
Come on,
see if he could pull that up.
That's brilliant,
Dan.
We need to hear that.
I think people have different things.
Some people like watching other people fuck.
And some people like watching porn,
pretending it's them,
you know,
look,
you're like,
oh,
that could be made.
That could be made.
You know,
some people like it's like,
like a being as a person,
being the person,
like actually just beating off,
watching people.
Fuck.
It's like two totally different mindsets for me.
It's just looking at the naked girl.
That's for me.
But I mean,
I don't know why I'm looking at that.
I'm looking at the leg,
I'm like,
that looks good.
I'm totally down with that.
But I have to put myself in a completely different mindset.
If it's a black guy,
it's a black guy,
fucking a white girl.
I have to go,
okay,
this is clearly not really mate.
I can't even pretend this is some weird poor when I had my blonde wig on,
forgetting you so hard.
I'm forgetting you so hard right now.
Lion's mane wig for while
we're watching people.
Fuck African Americans.
Fuck white girls.
Oh yeah.
Well there's a lot of guys who have like weird porn for it.
Basically cock holding.
It's called a special condition.
American cock,
Holden cut.
Colding and men want to be punked and they want another like manly man to fuck
their wife in front of them.
There's a lot of co Reebie dudes.
There's a lot of guys wrestling,
a weird fucking freak fetishes,
man.
You think there's blue home size about their chicken?
Fuck that white guy.
Sure.
Massive gonna come over with fuck you ain't his
massive
and here skank beaver.
It's from point.
I'm sure.
Whatever's,
whatever's forbidden,
man,
whatever the fuck is forbidden.
Someone's doing it.
Here's pillow.
A psychological benefit.
This is Joshua here at porn for the blind.
Dot.
Or homeless.
Oh my God,
you are am presented with a clip to his voice showing a woman in a glass of
white substances and
fired.
You're fired.
Get scrolled down the page and find myself another audition today.
Wish me luck quick.
Come on.
No wait.
All right.
The video is starting with a woman who is young and attractive and Tan laying
back on a bed.
And
what just happened is this is fucked.
This is bullshit.
This fitting.
Nope.
Hey We,
let me explain.
This is a community based website and if you look at the screen right now,
there's a whole bunch of them that people put on there.
So some of them definitely are fake,
but some of them are.
I've listened to it.
Well that guy,
that one guy was clearly trying to be an asshole.
Right.
You can tell just by the way he was talking,
you know,
like,
you know what,
it would have been just as funny if he would've just kept the act,
right?
Yeah,
exactly.
If you want to do,
if you're going to do a porn for the blind and describe someone fucking man,
you better stop horny.
There's people just hate blind,
you know,
you can't be like,
well she's taking out his cock.
You know,
it's not like a special thing.
This guy's not excited.
I got an offer from,
would they lie also with like kind of just like,
you know,
I mean,
cause it's like phone,
sex,
right?
So you're on a phone with like some chick,
you don't know what she looks like.
Of course she was saying she's all this and she's all that.
So,
but they kind of just fudge in sub shit.
Our good friend of Maryland Martinez,
we uh,
she passed away recently.
We'd love her to death.
She was awesome.
Great comedian.
Really funny lady that used to hang around the comedy store.
She was a phone sex operator and she was probably five feet tall.
Yeah.
She's maybe like legitimately phone shoes.
And she was a big woman.
She was really big.
I knew her.
I just didn't know she was,
she was really unhealthy and that she was,
she was big.
She,
yeah,
she was doing false sex.
She would come and talk about it at the comedy store.
It was hilarious.
He would have been a great TV show.
She was alive today.
It would've been a great TV show cause she was hilarious and she was great in
describing all these fucking freaks that would call her up.
Yeah.
Like toes and my ass.
Oh baby.
I got my toe in your ass right now and yeah,
my tells me.
Yeah.
I look like I'm like fucking Tozier ass if she would go,
oh yeah,
these sick fucks.
They just,
they want to hear all kinds of shit.
I gave it to an important recently,
Lauren out there on somewhere.com,
uh,
with,
a guy at a mouse head on a chick.
Oh,
I shit you not.
that's awesome.
That's weird.
And I get that asked all the time and it was like,
oh,
would you,
what would you do with check somewhere?
I wouldn't,
somewhere down the line prosthetics,
somewhere down the line of process is going to get so good that you're going to
have to,
you're gonna be able to watch like JFK fucking Marilyn Monroe.
I'm kind of scared about this shit.
I really am not,
not,
not like,
uh,
in terms of fucking dude in a fucking mouse hat or whatever.
But I think about it,
you know,
where people are getting convicted on,
CCTV footage or doing shit like that with today's like CG artists and shit like
that.
Oh,
it's absolutely true.
We could fuck a dude up.
Do you remember rat wag the dog?
Remember that Dustin Hoffman movie?
I haven't seen that.
It was a movie about a,
they were the,
they faked some,
some military action and it was a political movie.
And it was a,
you know,
a lot of it was special effects they use.
They brought in Hollywood guys and I was thinking,
you know,
today,
God,
it would be so easy.
It really,
really is so easy to fake something.
Be So easy.
Isn't that fucking scare the shit out here?
A little bit terrifying.
It's terrifying thinking that they restrict dubbing my shit right now with me
hours.
What do you mean?
Oh yeah,
like fuck.
You know it's not hard to do a recent law passed by Congress.
It's going to have hundreds of thousands of drones in the sky.
Did or the thought more than something like more than 30 million people.
Have you been fucking put him in orbit cameras,
cameras in the sky to watch over the seat,
the city streets.
The idea is,
hey man,
if you're not doing anything bad,
but what if you trying to fuck in an alleyway somewhere?
What if you're with your girl and you just like,
come on you dirty bitch.
Someone's going to see,
you're like,
shut up.
I was going to say come on baby,
and I was going to say,
okay,
quick be quick,
be quick.
And now you're on.
You're on the government's fucking video because of that,
because there's a little spaceship in the sky.
It's Erica there.
This is the government.
We've seen your,
your boys bull shit.
I think they have larger agendas you
think,
but
you would think,
but 28 high school kids got arrested recently because they hired cops to pretend
to be undercover.
They pretend to be high school kids.
It was like 21 fucking jump street,
but just hanging around or try and push it.
Trying to buy weed.
Oh that's [inaudible] 28 high school kids arrested in Florida for weed because
cops pretended to be high school.
You would think that they would use the resources wisely,
but if they could get you for sexual exposure outside,
you know,
especially by the way,
if you're anywhere near a school,
if you were within a certain amount of yards of a school,
even that's all of a sudden you're a sexual predator.
You know?
Like if you take a leak outside of a a children's school,
you do
crazy drifter.
If you're an idiot,
you don't know any better.
You can't find a bathroom
walk around the back of the bathroom.
There's no bathroom.
Women will just piss on wall.
All right,
so last night for that.
If they arrest you for that,
you're a sexual Predator will.
Yeah.
A lot of places.
If you're in a park that's got to be showing up around the house,
you know,
like don't piss the nearest school.
What's really crazy is when you get
fucking branded really tome pies.
Cool,
dude,
we should be rebels and tonight and just go PA school just to do it.
I'm not doing it do,
especially after we talked about on the Internet.
The government is going to know they're gonna have the droves out.
By the time they're telling you that there's drones,
there's fucking dirty bin drones here to be placed on this on a daily base.
Damn it.
What is it called?
The time they talk about cloning,
while we're going to try calling the guy telling you is probably a clone.
There've been clawing forever.
There's no way they're going to tell you the common person when they're ready to
clone people.
They'll,
they'll make all sorts of experiments before we let people know.
They probably already have.
Absolutely.
I mean if they thought that they could make an army of psychotic fucking robot
flesh people if they thought they could clone you and take out all your morality
was the
first attempt,
how much money would they make?
If they just call it hot bitches and they just fucking sell flood the market,
we can't do that.
The real money,
then it'd be different.
Didn't the ugly peer personally valued money would really be and killing them
off and getting a small number of them like pearls.
Would that be true if they,
if they cloned all hot,
like hot grow,
so it was like hot girl was more than ugly girl with the ugly girl.
Be The hot girl.
Actually she would because she would rent that one.
She'd be a lower collectible.
[inaudible] got this limited bucking edition one offs and smells.
It's Swartz and Eggers nanny
for line addition.
They did it in Sweden.
That's where the slug in the ditch came from is I have an overdub of a him
Chang,
you son of a bitch and say you're slugging a ditch and the whole thing was off
and that was Arnold.
What was I saying?
I don't know.
Cloning.
We're running into each other a lot here.
They don't have enough time.
But when you,
when you get marijuana and alcohol together in one row and everybody saw that
shit.
Arnold Schwarzenegger's voice.
Yeah,
but that,
that was an interjection.
That wasn't in the discussion.
I forgot.
We were talking about cloning hot chicks.
Yeah,
well I will say that Sweden,
they did that.
Why do you gen x?
They actually let,
they would for 30 40 50 years.
This is where the Nazis got all their shit in Sweden.
That's why all the hot chicks come from Sweden and good looking dudes too.
If you'd like that shit.
They all come from Sweden,
Swedish house.
There's a lot of hot chicks from all over the world,
but I'm,
I know what you're saying.
There's a large,
yeah,
this
was Sweden was all about what's best for the country and they thought that based
on the symmetry of your face,
whether you're or not,
they should reproduce.
So if you had a baby,
they will look at the baby and they would analyze it.
Scientists make sure everything is 300 and take it to the clinic.
They would sterilize the baby if she wasn't perfect symmetry.
When did this happen?
This is real shit.
Eugenics.
This is where the Nazis got all their shit from Sweden,
man,
this look into it son.
It's crazy.
That's why all the good looking people like you go to,
how long are they engineer this for?
It was something like it was part of their country.
They convince the entire nation that the country was above you personally.
So when you had a baby,
the scientists analyze the baby and if it was perfect,
they would let it breed.
Someone's writing some script as we speak.
You,
you've never heard of this.
This is real.
They really,
this is good.
I mean,
I mean I got a lot of free time,
but man in Sweden,
there's a lot of good looking people.
Man.
I've been there like three times and every five minutes here,
five years or every five minutes.
That was the timing that I thought because everywhere I would look,
I would,
I was going to try and explain it to my friends.
I'm like,
the only way you can explain it,
I want to average every five minutes to see a supermodel.
You're like,
it's you go to Mcdonald's at all.
Amazing.
Sweden's government said on Wednesday that it had commissioned a study into why
eugenics was involved in the country in the 19th and 20th centuries leading to
tens of thousands being sterilized by force.
I told Jermaine sterilize being a euphemistic term for just
killing it,
sterilized,
sterilized.
They have a clip your balls man and the bolt on your
ovaries.
Think about why they did it based on the shape of your face.
They thought based on the symmetry of your face that like you had good genes,
you are ugly,
you are not producing.
That's the way it was
incredible.
Listen to this.
A fundamental aim is to find out what the society that had developed this
eugenics mentality and established,
accepted scientific research in the area,
look like the Swedish minister and above blah,
blah,
blah.
Said in a statement,
and this is the social philosophy of Eugenics,
which advocates the improvement of human hereditary traits through social
intervention developed in Sweden and elsewhere in Europe during the 18 hundreds
before becoming the basis for widespread racial policies in the 20th century.
That's fucking incredible.
So that's why most extreme form is [inaudible] is so good looking,
man.
Well that's,
you know,
the were the worst thing anyone has ever said was Hitler had a great idea,
but it just took it too far.
It's like the worst thing that anybody ever said.
And it's like,
well,
it's one of the things we,
you go,
Whoa,
whoa.
You can't fucking say it can't even,
you can't accept any of his ideas.
It's Hitler.
But this is what they're saying.
They're saying like this idea that human beings had to realize that people live
and people die and the right way to move the species forward is to get the
basketball.
You have to remember at the time when that was employed to the,
the ignorance
they'd be going around and there wasn't
the communication available.
Like,
you know,
the Internet and the politics were obviously way up for fucking scoop.
They don't understand is the right and they're wrong.
But at the same time they're there,
right as a mathematical program.
They're wrong as a species.
The species,
the marriage should be to whatever the,
the rest of the species fines,
you know,
a attractive fines would.
They're drawn to whatever they like,
whatever the,
whether it's blonde hair and blue eyes,
whatever the area is we're doing or one of the very,
very few species that even fucking take that into consideration.
Whereas,
you know,
other species in the animal fucking kingdom,
we just let it,
let it go.
Yeah,
whatever.
Fuck.
Exactly.
The idea that we want to engineer it,
it's nonsense.
It's,
to me it's a massive form of control freak is.
Um,
but it's based on science.
They're trying to make like the genetically the perfect species.
But I say that's ridiculous cause it's not about that.
It's not,
it's not about like what looks the best,
what's the most sexually attracted?
What,
what has the best,
a lot of it is about the brain.
A lot of it is about the mind and the mind's reaction to all the experiences of
life and how the mind develops and the mind of a,
a Geek,
you know,
what are you going to engineer all the geeks out engineer?
Y'All fucking inherit the Earth Day.
But they're there.
They're on,
they're on the computer level.
They're,
they're,
uh,
attacking in the mental form.
The idea that you've got to eliminate the most progressive aspect of society.
The people that are the people that are fluent in computer technology and
creating infrastructure that this whole fucking internet runs on the idea that
you're going to eliminate them.
It's this silly that's so short sighted.
It's so stupid.
Be Like idiocracy.
Yeah.
Well you've,
I'm,
you've engineered yourself into a corner.
We,
you think that you,
because,
because you're attracted to broad cheeks,
like that's what everybody needs.
That's right.
If that was true of eugenics was true,
maybe on a physical sense is pure physical,
not emotional,
intellectual for a worker it would be good for sex work.
Do I get a piss break?
It would mean to go through that door.
There's a,
the last door on the left.
Think about,
I like that you're still rocking the wallet chain.
Iraq one as well.
This one,
today's leather,
but a lot,
oftentimes the worst steel.
Nice man.
It's my girlfriend shitting in their,
just pee on her.
Now we're talking,
by the way,
I got to talk about this because Eddie and I were talking about this on the way
over.
Uh,
there's an article on some Internet.
What's wrong?
Is she coming back then?
She's not really,
I think she's in the bathroom.
You should really in there.
I think so.
Don't,
don't,
don't wait.
I'll wait.
What a man holding a gentlemen.
Hold it.
We were talking about this as home article about some porn star who made,
apparently she made $1 million going to the Middle East and having sex with like
really rich guys,
the wall royal guys and she,
you know,
she talked about it and she had like this online interview,
which is talking about all the different crazy shit they would rake her,
do like have sex with German shepherds,
drink a glass of calm.
And one of them was,
they showed up pretty all showed up.
This is so crazy cause I just read this today.
They,
she,
she said,
she said they showed up and you know,
they said it was supposed to be really,
they didn't know what
the fuck that meant.
You know,
she's like,
I've seen it all.
When they go on a,
they're on a boat,
they will show up on a yacht.
There's all these dudes are like 50 you know the dude's say,
all right,
take your clothes off.
Start playing with yourself.
So they all say,
all right cool.
And then guys come along and start pissing on them and they want him to open up
their mouth and went to,
I want to piss their mouth.
They started shitting on girls like,
and the girls were,
some of the girls screamed like,
fuck this.
Like are you,
you're not going to get paid.
You can go over there and sit and wait until we,
you know,
pulling the doc,
this is what we do.
And so that's what they do.
That's where their homework and they pay these people a fuck load of money and
just piss on him and shit on them.
It's like,
wow,
you've got to consider the health risk.
Yeah,
that's gotta be expensive.
Well,
the urine is the Zeros,
Neil risk,
but a shit.
There's a high risk
you're in.
You can drape people's person.
That's really good.
No,
she's like,
you got to pay a bitch to shit on her.
That's crazy.
Thousand Dollars.
That's just not going to happen.
Crazy thing.
What of the girls said,
one of the girls who was in there said that after you get shit on the third
time,
it's like no big deal.
Like she remembers like when she became numb third time I would think it would
some trillionaire shit on her chest.
You've got to pay a bitch at these.
She's got to be thinking like,
you know,
1520 grand cash.
This girl said was that in the article with this girl said,
was that after uh,
whatever she's done over there for how long she did it.
She had $1 million in the bank and she was retiring to the million dollars cash
and she was done and she was like 28 years old or something like that.
I'm like,
wow.
But she was like super honest about all the different shit they forced her to
do.
And I was like,
whoa.
You know,
she thought she had,
you know,
doing porn and stuff.
She had like seen it all and she's like,
you know,
you can over there and they're making you fuck dogs.
Was that
damn fucking dogs must be expensive.
That's going to be the right spot.
A dog run slow.
I don't know how long this broad
said she made a million mouses phone.
If you hear that vibrating,
come on.
You had all the money in the world.
Damn.
You might have to just go right big.
Well you don't tell him about it.
You can't tell him about it and tell them about what about the gotta Fuck dogs
until they get there.
Well,
you know what I was thinking
they start off with cats,
you know what I'm saying?
You ease them into the door.
You can't talk about the dog and the email.
The dog that quick,
they got to see the money.
You show them a pile of money,
stacks of hundreds and then then the dog comes.
I think what happens is they get bored heard.
They get bored and what they can get these girls to do.
What the fuck did,
I started ranting it up.
We were talking about really rich dudes in the Middle East.
Oh,
okay.
There was a whole,
there's a whole like thing of him like a network of them,
but some girl busted it all out because she got caught with her laptop and then
like the cat was out of the bag and it turned out that a lot of these girls that
were going over there to quote unquote model,
we're actually going over there and they were like really famous girls.
You know like you can
find them on in movies and TV shows and stuff.
I think they just have bad management,
you know what I mean?
Cause if you don't get those,
like the kind of points defined right.
You know,
no matter what the fuck it is,
you know,
if you're being paid to over there,
play music,
you know,
I mean I've heard of like prolific Dj's going out to countries,
you know what I mean?
And then they go and do the show as commission,
But literally in some of these more like volatile countries and shit like that,
you know,
they would be like,
dude,
you're going to play this song and you have to play the song.
And if you don't,
basically we'll take you out back and fucking fuck you up big time.
Uh,
what?
Yeah,
I've heard of things.
Nudes.
Oh yeah,
dude.
Even I even have some fucking horror stories.
Yeah,
but what countries are the issues?
You can't talk about it with me.
No,
I just,
no,
I don't want to just give a heard of anybody in the country that you can talk
about a specific country.
No,
I just don't want to go there.
But I'm just saying,
let's just say at a dodgy country and,
um,
you know,
you're asked to perform and all this stuff and uh,
say you're known for something else too.
And they,
and that's not part of what you're Johnny Walker and they want you to say dyno.
Exactly.
You got to say,
you have to do it.
You have to fucking do it.
You know what I mean?
And they're like,
dude,
you know,
and then it gets gnarly,
and you can say,
look,
dude,
this isn't in the order,
the work order kind of thing.
You know what I mean?
They're like,
we don't give a fuck.
They just,
hey,
closed and stuff.
Yeah,
like that.
You know what I mean?
I know it's not that bad.
I'd do it anyway,
but you know it like,
like say that,
you know what I mean?
If I don't play ghosts and stuff in the fucking said fuck in place,
you know,
he gets really fucking gnarly.
You're essentially out there on your fucking own,
you know what I mean?
With you and whoever you're with,
your tour manager and shit like that.
So you don't exactly have a personal army to fucking back your shit up if
you're,
you know,
being threatened to do something.
So sometimes you just say,
you know what,
fuck it.
Do it.
You know,
because when you start to get in people's faces about,
Yo dude,
I'm,
I'm done.
And the people have like,
or do they,
I should say,
do they try to have,
when they book you for things?
Well that's the funny thing.
There are kind of like two levels of the whole like,
you know,
at least with my experience of being a performer,
a one is like,
you know the gay for pay,
you know,
you go,
you know what you're getting into,
you go and you do it,
you just get out and that's it.
And then the other ones like,
you know,
you go there and then the rules change,
you know what I mean?
But there's not much like,
you know,
have a dictator.
They are medic mediator to come in and say,
you know,
hey look,
this isn't in this and you know,
you have to like go above and beyond and all this shit.
So you're playing for these people.
You know,
first and foremost,
when I go to play a show,
I'm there for everyone that's there.
You know what I mean?
I'm not there for the fucking Dickhead who may be paying me some insane figure
to fucking be there.
But the Dickhead who does pay you some insane figure to fucking be there is
like,
you know,
they're like,
they take that big lump or whatever and say,
this is my justification for making you my bitch tonight.
And you know what I mean?
And this is about me and my company and how we're going to,
so I've been the show low levels.
Yeah,
exactly.
Or you know,
I was low in high.
Yeah.
We're like,
dude,
well no,
we just totally paid you to do this.
So we,
we,
we own you.
But you know,
as long as you go into the attitudes,
it's like,
look,
it's like I'm going to go ahead and go do something extra anyway,
but only because it's like,
shit dude,
I see like the whole first,
you know,
in 20 rows of fucking smiley faces and they're all having fun despite all this
bullshit that's going on between me and a promoter,
you know?
So the thing about,
you know,
like Djs and shit like that is that,
when they're starting out,
you're always working for someone.
You know what I mean?
Like,
no matter what,
you're going to a club,
you're playing for the club owner because he's the guy that's paying your
fucking bill.
Um,
and you know,
hopefully a point where you turn,
it becomes your production and it's your crew and it's your production company.
Cause I mean,
like I said,
the signing a deal with live nation was like the best thing I could have done
for myself because you know,
live nation is huge and I would help out with do concerts through them.
They're awesome.
Right?
So,
but then it no,
once your show,
you know,
not,
not and so and so presents Joe fucking retro is cool.
The representatives are only,
and then you can always walk into a show.
I have a great fucking time emails from random promoter dudes and I'm like,
this is
great.
But it'd be good to be Uber Sketchy.
Pain the ass.
Yeah.
Had those can't get paid.
Get to a point to where you can,
you can really know who's cool and not,
you know,
like I have like,
like a Dream Team of promoters and you know,
there are many of them,
like maybe 20 or 30 of dudes that high would even fucking hang with.
You know what I mean?
In playing for those guys,
it's always fun.
And Greg,
I've got a bunch of those guys in Canada,
you'll always get this one fucking dude.
You know what I mean?
Who just puts in this insane offer?
And of course,
you know your agencies just like,
yeah,
Foa,
Shit Dude,
check out this fucking smash and grab all she has to do with this.
And then you show up and then it's like,
dude,
you're my bitch basically,
so you have to do this,
you have to fucking do that and here's your time slot and I'll give a shit.
You know?
And then you're,
you're bummed out because of that,
obviously,
but you're not bummed out because there are fuck tons of fucking,
you know,
kids that came to fucking see you in the fall.
And that's the only thing that really kind of makes it all worthwhile.
When you get into a situation like that,
what is the big,
uh,
the big toss up over?
Is it the set list?
Is it,
you know,
like I,
this is my type of music,
this is what the kids want to hear sometimes it used to be,
you know what I mean?
Until like,
you know,
I Kinda,
I kinda made my own thing and that's obviously what they're buying in the first
place.
So they're never going to question you on that.
But it's,
it's usually,
you know,
just some kind of time constraint or something,
where they get other acts too,
which,
you know,
and like I said,
the,
the funnier it,
the easier it gets is when you just say,
you know what?
Fuck it.
Let it,
let everyone do what they want.
You know what I mean?
If fucking DJ super awesome wants to cut my set by 15 minutes and then,
you know,
early in your career,
it's always a pissing contest.
And so it was like,
no,
I'm not doing it.
If that's not having,
then I'm not going on.
If they cut me this much,
I'm not going on.
And then you see it a lot,
you know what mean?
But then you get to a point where I was like,
all right,
let them let them,
you know,
because you can always explain this shit and,
and,
and one of the beautiful things I find with my,
you know,
horde of fucking fans is that I can always just tell it how it is.
You know what I mean?
So then after you have the opportunity,
now I always,
you know,
and I kind of always try to always did,
you know what I mean?
So,
and then if everyone says,
well dude,
you know,
oh,
why did you get cancelled at this?
And then I can just say,
look like you can make a blog entry.
Absolutely.
Explaining yourself.
You don't have to wait for a reporter to kite and you don't kind of bull shit
anyone.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
You could just tell her right there and then it is,
well listen,
I really apologize,
but it's because of this is why we couldn't do this.
You know,
and then the more laid back you are when it comes to that stuff.
And this was really good advice,
especially for like,
I don't,
I don't want to categorize them but like see list guys that wanted,
you know,
that get put on these massive bills with like tons of fucking dudes.
You know,
it's just not to be all like super,
you know,
lit Tejas and weird and antsy and just agro in general about you know,
what time you're given because you know,
the more relaxed you are about it,
you know,
just get the fucking job done.
Dude.
You're,
you're,
you're mirroring standup comedy.
I mean it's,
it must be the exact same mentality in the,
the rising comedian as it is in the rising electronic Dj.
It's the same story,
the same thing.
You have to listen to people until everybody's coming to see you and then you
don't have to listen to anybody anymore.
It's the same thing.
And then it's just all out and then it's you and them and not to them
about third party doing shows with a gang of other people about,
you know,
your toms your time.
Don't worry about it all that.
Don't be so locked up and in rigid.
Let it go and then just go up when you go up and do your shit.
Yeah.
And if you don't get up and if something apt epically fucked up so bad,
you can always just say explain it.
Yeah.
You explain.
Look,
it looked up so bad because total dickhead brought all this shit and that's what
it was.
There's a lot of conflict when acts like tour together.
The only time I ever toured with anybody,
I toured with John,
half,
Ron and Charlie Murphy and one time my,
you know,
we were all doing like different w what it was was Charlie Murphy was headlining
one night and then I would headline the next night and no matter what happened,
trolley Murphy never gave a fuck.
There could be some crazy,
the room could've gone on fire for half an hour while to learn that.
That for him.
No Man for me.
Yeah,
definitely.
You know,
it took me a while to learn how to relax.
I still don't know it.
I get it and then I lose it.
It's like sand slipping.
Do I?
The fingers from a Dj Knick Fan.
Chuli he just always said to me,
he just would always say the only thing ever added this guy's fucking mouth,
which
dude relax.
Yeah,
he's right.
he's totally fine.
He's totally right.
You know?
Um,
it just relax.
If you've done the work,
you know,
you say relax.
If you're ready,
relax.
If you've done the work,
which you should be,
you're a fucking professional and whenever you're doing.
But yeah,
I,
I kid,
when I say that,
I don't really have control of it because I don't ever want to believe that I
have control of it because I don't want to sleep.
I don't want to rest on it and let it creep up on me and burn the house down.
All right.
You know,
the,
the human mind's a fairy fucking tricky thing,
man.
It's gotta be kept on pointing,
always on his tippy toes,
you know?
But I that,
that feeling of a,
it's a very frustrating feeling of having somebody else trying to influence what
the fuck you're trying to do.
You know,
when you're,
uh,
you're,
you're coming up as a,
a digital artist,
as a comedian,
I think as anything people want to define you and they have their own ideas and
the same thing that made you not be a good website designer and be like,
bitch,
if I want to do it and blue,
it's going to be blue.
That's like your music,
you know?
And that's how you have to be as a comedian too.
I think they're very much the same.
It's like,
in order to,
to really get your point across,
you,
you have to all have a solitary vision,
you know?
Do you have a crew,
uh,
as far as the,
what we hear from you
musically,
I really liked to kind of just run the show there,
but I have a crew for the show who helped me with the visuals,
that technology,
the cube stuff,
all the led mouse,
everything and come up with everything.
And you record everything and produced musically.
Yes.
Wow.
Yeah.
Well,
it's fun,
you know,
like,
and that's kind of what kind of got it all started for me.
You know,
I,
I didn't come out of the gate as a,
you know,
the purveyor and awesome play button pusher of other people's wars stuff,
original music or sampled half and half.
No,
never sampled.
That's everything.
Yeah,
I really like to do that.
Um,
and just keep it that way.
Just,
you know,
obviously for the whole like,
well,
we don't have to pay out fucking serious like sync fees or licensing or buying
the rights to,
you know,
you'd make a derivative work of something that's already been done.
That's something I like really like to avoid.
So you've never sampled anything?
No.
Yeah,
I have actually.
I'm,
I have sampled a couple things,
uh,
but they were just like a little boutique tracks.
It never really went out and made it big.
Are there any samples that you've heard in your head that you wanted a sample
but you're like,
fuck,
it's too much of a headache to,
well,
it's never,
it's never a headache to do it.
It's easier to ask for forgiveness than it is permission.
Really.
What happened?
Business work explained this to me.
Well,
what happens when like Mc Hammer makes it song like can't touch this.
Well Dan do as fucking directed.
You can't touch it.
That's like the ultimate anti sample right there.
He is at the mash ups.
Do you enjoy mash up?
Sold all the answer the question.
Hold on.
What?
What does that mean?
What happens there?
Who gets the money?
Who gets the money for MC Hammer remix?
You can't touch this if I take,
you can't touch this and put this into dance track.
No,
that's not what I'm saying.
What do you say touch.
This is Rick James.
It's she's super free.
Well he couldn't touch it.
Don't,
no,
no.
I'm saying that the track that is that Rick's Jane.
That's a Rick derivative work.
Completely.
Okay.
So how has that worked?
As James gets money,
there are some laws that would dictate,
you know,
that it's a cover as opposed to a direct sampling of the recording.
Now these laws are still not even close to,
you know,
super defined.
You know,
so it's always the case.
It's always a musicologist involved.
And especially with like vanilla ice is ice ice baby,
which was the other match.
His,
his whole defense to all that was,
it's not Denon and then [inaudible] he was like,
no,
it's Dannon and then,
and then,
and then I'm like,
wow.
Yeah.
You know,
it said there are like certain things you can get away with.
It used to be like kind of like a general apply rule where you could say,
okay,
well then fine.
No more than three seconds should be the rule.
You know what I mean?
And then,
and then it's obviously changed because people can recreate the exact same thing
just as easily 10 say.
It's like the constant,
you know,
like that,
those,
that,
those songs pissed me off.
That's like,
you're just making me think of like some cool old song.
But I used to like,
I would still just call it a remax.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
It's a remix,
remake,
remix,
cover,
all that stuff.
I actually recently did a cover of a Radiohead Song Codex off,
uh,
the king of limbs.
Now,
uh,
the way that I did that is,
um,
you know,
I,
I'm a huge Radiohead fan,
so I kind of took it as myself as an exercise to see if I could reproduce it as
close to as possible.
Minus obviously is fucking amazing vocal and I share it because I can't sing for
a fuck.
So,
um,
you know,
I remade his track and threw it up on soundcloud,
just kind of like,
you know,
with the huge disclaimer saying,
dude,
this is not,
there's,
this is not a remix.
And I hate to say it,
the whole thing as an artistic exercise and you know,
I don't plan on monitorizing off that.
If I actually had planned on anything,
it was just getting,
you know,
fucking Yo Thom Yorke,
what app?
You know what I mean?
He,
you know,
so I do a lot of things like that and I've done it with boards of Canada who are
this like Scottish group that I like absolutely love and um,
you know,
and,
but as long as I have like,
Hey,
yeah,
this is going to be on my next album,
check it out at,
no,
no in,
you know,
in kind of sort of sell people on the vibe that Oh,
this is my big thing.
This is original because you know how many vanilla ice fans fucking I'll be at
16 to 20 years old and even knew who their fucking Eurythmics wa,
you know what I mean?
So that could have been David Bowie and Mick Jagger,
wasn't it?
Or under pressure pressure queen,
Queen,
Queen.
Fuck.
Yeah,
that's right.
That's right.
Your rhythmic and I'm thinking about sweet dreams and it was queen.
Yeah.
It's a mate.
Who the fuck gets the money for that though?
Wow.
They go to court over that quarter with it.
They probably got permission for the member.
The verve.
You remember that song is a bittersweet symphony.
I apparently they lost all their money to the rolling stones,
took the music without asking.
It's very acceptable to sample music and then just wrap over it.
But no one really is sampled music and song over it.
We're sampling shit.
Is that what they did?
They sampled it.
They just took the rolling stones music.
It was amazing.
Either way.
I'm telling you,
I dude,
I've had motherfuckers whole
songs of mine and not change a thing except for like a speed or a pitch of it
and then pass it off as,
hey,
this is my new thing with no even and oh here's this is dead mouse the track and
you're always going to fucking get that.
You know what I mean?
It's due by fucking bitch is going to fucking bite your jokes.
You're just going to get that.
But you know a Doug Stan hope.
Do you know Doug Stanton?
I don't know shit.
Doug.
Stan helps a hilarious comedian and he,
uh,
some guy was taking his bits and verbatim writing them out as if they are blog
entries is,
this is like word for word brilliant drunk and ramblings on society and hey,
muscle pain in the place to be.
Why don't you at the June on my brother
Russell Peters has just entered the building with,
uh,
there's some people here and everyone's saying hi.
Oh Chris.
Yeah,
no shit.
He was a fucking grip on it.
Oh,
see these Canadians,
man,
when they get together all of a sudden,
hey,
your brother,
my brother worked on his show.
Canadians love Canadians.
Fuck
that guy.
Just me and my fucking day because my brother,
God bless him.
You know,
he's not successful and he's not like wide known,
but he really wants to get into film and television and gripping and all that
stuff.
And I didn't even know he fucking did that.
And now that you said that,
I gotta,
I gotta call my brother one of the greatest show totally gave you a fucking big
APP.
Russell Peters is one of the greatest humans has ever lived.
I love this guy.
Maintain that.
Let's keep this half a beer.
My brother drank beer but fuck it.
Come on.
There's any Merona is left.
Here's one running on.
That's mine.
I don't want my spit bro.
Joe,
we'll get some more.
We'll get some more for you.
All right.
Give me a list of the bands that influenced Russell Peters in the
beginning.
Just real quick.
Yes.
Frozen
there.
My homeboys got a hard head when he heard you were going to be here.
Oh No.
Hey
that's breezy.
Only two black dudes can walk in and be called Blade and breezy and nobody
freaks out blazing breezy and nobody,
nobody goes.
Do we lose the uh,
the video?
I had an epic bike guy freak out at my house.
I'm doing renovations right now.
So an epic black guy and it was fucking hilarious.
It was.
He's cause I have about 16 construction workers.
I'll just kind of in and out of the house like for the last uh,
six months cause we were doing a big renovation.
Right.
So I don't know any of them.
And all this stuff.
And I'm only home for like two days,
right.
So they start at 9:00 AM but no one told me this shit.
Right.
So the biggest fucking black dude just kind of walks in and uh,
I don't know what to fucking,
cause I wasn't expecting anyone,
but he was like one of the people working on the studio and stuff like that.
And I just kind of stopped.
He didn't knock,
you just kind of busted in like he would,
cause I wasn't there,
so he was supposed to do that and I just like kind of froze for a bit,
cause like,
dude,
this dude is just walking into my fucking house.
And so I turned around,
I'm like,
dude,
can I help you?
And he's like,
what?
Yeah,
I'm supposed to be working on your place.
And then it clicked,
right?
And then I was like,
oh my God.
Oh,
okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
And then all of a sudden,
all the other fucking dudes caught on to me,
you know,
calling this guy,
as he's walking into my fucking house.
And he went,
Oh yeah,
the big black dude fucking walks into your fucking blaze.
You freaking out or you thought he was gonna rob you and then and then
no,
just turned on your Canadian.
I,
dude,
I just fucking,
totally,
you're talking to different black dude.
You're talking black Canadians in different guys.
Black Canadians are the nicest people ever.
David Lowe.
Razo Nice.
Fucked up.
I mean,
could you imagine?
I was sitting in my boxers on the fucking computer and are you ready to rock?
We'll be thinking.
I'm like,
dude,
can I help you?
He was
thinking this next mix beat.
Yeah,
that's a,
that's a fucking freaky moment when anybody's in your house.
We're not prepared.
Especially a big Buckeye.
Was this in Canada or here in Toronto?
Toronto or even say cafe area.
No,
Toronto.
I live in Toronto.
That's all right.
Don't get crazy slower times on the trials.
You'll watch out.
I live in Toronto.
Throw it.
Slow it down.
They're angry.
Red.
Toronto's a bad ass city man.
I fucking love Toronto.
Toronto loves Joe Rogan.
I did a comedy club dinner.
Bravo.
I did a comedy club there in uh,
it was a,
a pot shop and uh,
people were allowed to smoke weed in Toronto was going on.
Yeah.
I don't want to say the name.
I don't even say where it is.
You go there,
you go there it's like a bong shop.
They take in this back room and there's not a fan and the place,
there's no air.
There's no air.
The whole place gray man.
It's like you're flying through the clouds was called ridiculous cafe contact
high.
It was the most ridiculous thing I've ever been a part of.
We know
it's called Henry comes with a Goddamn posy.
Yeah.
I'm not fucking around the roll deep pit.
That's a,
that,
that's Dylan Garcia and you know,
hey Suze,
don't you?
Hey,
my name is Trey hoe.
He worries,
they're both comments from left,
uh,
from the comedy store.
Nice.
Russell Peters does not travel by himself.
Do you have a tour bus or something?
She,
they came in to cars full
hanging out or we live here.
He's Indian man.
You don't know hard.
Okay.
Cardi was saying that we were going to hook up one day.
You have a green card and you still buy houses in America.
You're a savage has been in a fuck.
If I didn't know for sure,
if I had to buy a house for fuck sakes.
Oh please.
How long?
How long have you been?
Uh,
uh,
she gets the house Wednesday.
Wednesday.
Wow.
You knew it was coming.
We had a conversation a year ago.
Russ just see this was the parent for impact.
He's putting helmets on his shit.
I had my head between my legs,
elbow pads.
He knew it was coming.
He knows.
He knew the rocks were there.
I knew that my seat was a flotation device.
Boat was hitting the rock sons.
There's no doubt about it.
Hey,
it is what it is.
But it all worked out great.
It works.
You're Russell Peters.
You went,
we're actually cooler now than we were when we were together.
That's beautiful.
She'd probably love you now that you should respect you,
that you got away from her bullshit.
She girls,
girls need that.
And then when they're in a situation where you cannot ever leave,
like we have a child together,
there's girls that abused guys because they're,
they're constantly in this psychological drama,
this see saw battle of putting guys on the defensive.
So the guy proves that he's a man.
Like I dated a girl that I always wanted to fight and I was like,
I can't do this anymore.
She left and then she started dating some other dude and did the same goddamn
thing and then I had a call center and then you,
right,
exactly.
But I mean,
as a person,
I liked her as a person.
I was like,
what do you think's going on?
She's like,
I can't help it.
I have to push a guy.
She goes,
it's like,
it's in me.
I don't know what it is.
I want to push them into a corner and I want to get him to tell me to shut the
fuck up.
I want to know the heel.
He's willing to walk away from me,
otherwise I can't respect him.
It's true.
You can't walk away when you have a kid.
When you get one of those crazy bitches pregnant,
that's what happens.
Or they're stuck in a goddamn circuit loop.
It turns out mine was only crazy because of the hormones from being pregnant and
postpartum.
Oh,
let's put by that time I had already fucking checked out so it was too late.
You know the ironic part,
she's a big dead mouse fan and that's
sad if you know that man.
And why don't you guys try to get back together?
You're not,
um,
again,
her tickets I like,
are you guys friends still?
We're cool.
But you love,
you really loved her when you first met her,
right?
I was a rebound,
but it was um,
oh snap.
She fills the airways truths.
Hey,
wait,
why aren't we,
why aren't you at the Junos is here because they got shit or hosting it this
year.
I know how dope is there this year.
What are you going to do?
What are you guys don't know?
What does it,
Juno.
Juno's is a Canadian grammy.
Okay.
No one knows that.
You know,
the ironic thing is
running.
He's a Jew and I have a Juno's
and only Jewish.
When I'm in Hawaii.
Don't expect gold.
It's late and I'm drinking beer,
which I don't drink.
What you drink?
What do you do?
What would you like?
Can we get them alcohol in some form?
It's only one amp.
Hey,
you're next to show.
Oh,
we got some stuff.
You don't want this crown royal.
Trust me man.
Oh hell.
Just so fucking melt your tires breezy.
Can you hit the bar for me out there?
Is that,
how old is that crown?
It's pretty new.
I'm telling you.
Hey Joe,
you have the other stuff.
The other shit that a Rhonda Rousey.
The Glendale's.
What is an Armenian?
Well,
yeah man.
Armenians,
Bro.
I love Armenia.
Or Mommy is my people who's,
we're both Harry motherfuckers,
so we have to respect our meal.
We're very similar in genome Italian,
Indian army.
We are genetically predisposed to follicle not being follicly challenged.
They,
uh,
they hooked me up with some fucking Badass Cognac.
Dan,
this Exoskeleton,
the act,
it's really good,
man.
It's fucking neck.
Ronda Rousey came over and the armos sent this over with us.
She said,
the Armenians love me and they love when I talk good about Armenians.
So I'll talk about good about our means to the day I die when a grown man buys
me a bottle of cool Vasia,
he'd got me.
You will choke a Turk out for an
Xo.
It's the good shit.
It's the good,
what is it?
What kind of an alcoholic?
It's Martell Cognac.
It's the,
so that's of that.
That's the good stuff.
It's pretty fucking good.
You could tell by how fancy the bottom of this,
Brian,
until I saw God damn pot crumb.
You did that Santa,
I've watched the hair.
You.
How dare you.
Oh,
it's this.
It's this stack.
It was the wrong staff
through some shit.
And My gleans down stacks clean.
Asked.
You asked Wieden and that thousand apologies.
So do you like mashups?
Like do you enjoy living,
keep on Mashups,
or do you,
do you enjoy what people like do like it?
When people that don't do it do it.
Oh,
okay.
What does that make people that shouldn't do it?
Do.
I hate that I do enjoy the party band girl talk or any of that.
Hold on to say this guy,
by the way,
he,
you should've been here earlier because he completely mirrors your sentiments on
the whole Dj.
Like what is the definition of Dj?
He's an electronic artist.
Russell's a discs.
God knows it.
Do you know that?
We'll do.
I know what I've been deejaying since 85 have you really?
The Wolfman Jack Days.
I was on the radio back in the day,
me and mastermind,
we were had the hip hop shit.
No Shit on,
no,
no.
Wait eight.
We had the hip hop show and I was the DJ and the William Wayne Williams.
He was horrible.
It's a horrible human.
I'm good.
Thanks.
I've done it.
Yeah,
go for it.
He's going to get me a drink
cognac.
Oh,
Yay.
Hi.
No,
you want some cognac?
Cheers guys.
Long.
Yeah.
Fuck.
That's wow.
Whew.
You know what?
I love the occasional Jimi Hendrix smash up the Jay z Jimi Hendrix Mashup of
girl problems and Voodoo child.
That is the shit.
My favorite matchup was the gray album.
Oh,
danger mouse
all time favorite.
Masha was great too.
I agree.
You know,
that was,
mashups can be done in,
in such an artistic way that it's fucking cool.
But what about the bed Stuy meets blue eyes?
No,
it depends on how it's done,
but it's not bad.
That was my bad.
Yeah.
Anything with Biggie I love anything would be are such a big,
big fancy.
But when I was growing up,
they weren't called mashups.
They were just called mixes.
Right.
It was like growing up.
You would,
you would take whatever fucking acapella record they had because it was hard to
get acapellas back then.
So if a record had an Acapella,
you would fuck with it with however many beats you could find that would match
that acapella.
Like I would play sweetheart by rainy Davis and I would find as many fucking
beats that would go with that with sweetheart back in the day.
Then you would try and change them as much as fast as you could.
And that was the challenge because you'd have to dig the record out and you
didn't have the fucking bpms in front of you.
There was no sink button.
It's too susceptible to train wrecking though.
That's the problem with mash ups.
You know what I mean?
You could totally just mash something up and it sounds like shit.
There's very few people have a perception of music.
The way he does it.
It's almost creepy.
Like you have like a smell that I don't have.
I am a creepy music.
We played some music and he pulled,
he goes,
oh,
that's the salt and pepper in there.
The salt and pepper.
There's one,
and we were like,
what the fuck are you talking about?
Like a hundred times and break it down.
It's like,
stop this spot right here.
And we're like,
oh yeah.
Wow.
What the fuck?
How did you even pick that out man?
Like if you sample the snare and probably able to go,
I know where that snares wrong.
Yeah,
he'll,
he'll write the song.
It's really bizarre,
man.
It's,
it's,
it's still prevailing and music today,
even with the,
even the latest and greatest like electronic music,
cause you hear this one little sample or snare or something like that and it's
off another dude shit.
You know what I mean?
That's like kind of when I stopped fucking listening to music,
you know,
because I find that I'm analyzing.
It's like where did he get that?
Where did he just enjoy his homeboy wasn't in the back fucking hitting the snare
on the mic,
you know,
and they're all,
it's just,
just incestual ripping.
You know what I mean?
You could rip anything as long as it's good.
Right.
To put together the melodies that are magical and resonate with the planet.
That's the talent,
right.
Rip it off whether you sample it,
can you put together this unique little piece of art it's going to resonate with
the world.
Doesn't work that way with comedy.
It doesn't rustle.
P Not a couple of colleagues who do the collage for showed we got their best
stuff.
I business has a different code painting my wife,
you gotta you got to come up with your own riffs.
Yeah,
it's pretty awful.
And it's,
it's not getting any better.
We're out there.
It's,
well it isn't,
it isn't.
Fuck that I'm saying is,
do you ever write a great joke?
And then you think there's no way nobody did that.
I fucking Dick Jokes.
And I'm like so happy with it.
And then as soon as I get happy with it,
a go,
I'm sure some fucking guy said,
well,
you know,
I had a,
I had a bit that it was on one of my cds and I didn't find out until like four
years later that Ellen did generous.
Had a bit,
just like,
I did that in a special,
I did in 97 I did a joke
about throwing a fucking chocolate bar into a swimming pool or into a toilet or
just mashing it up.
I can't remember the fuck.
It was horrible.
And then,
and then how he Mendell was like,
you know,
I did that right.
I'm like,
son of a bitch.
And it was worse because how we did it and how are we on our friends?
Andy's Canadian.
So it was like,
it looks like I stole from my own fucking Pete.
The only thing you don't have to worry about with how he is,
he's not going to kick your ass cause you won't touch you.
Yeah,
it's true.
He's terrified of touching p.
It's true.
It's so you can be like,
what bitch?
Yeah,
I shake my head.
Start Sneezing.
He'll just run away from you man.
You never have to worry about it.
I'm kicking your ass.
Won't even shake your hand on the show yet.
What did pay him in how we met that up.
Oh,
it's like watching a Dj right now.
How dare you.
I think that's cool.
Keep telling him.
How dare you.
What do you tell him?
I tell we'd love anonymous 14 we'd love everyone.
[inaudible] dot com [inaudible] the shit so they don't take my website down.
English historian.
I paid a lot for that.com I need to seek it and take it down.
Hey digital mafia rules.
Well it's mostly like young hacker kids,
right?
I mean what is anonymous?
Anybody cannot miss this about like fucking 12 dudes.
Exactly,
exactly.
And I'm like,
Shit,
we just got down serious fucking government website.
I'm like,
did they really do that?
Yeah,
they can do that.
Absolutely.
Well,
this is how it works,
man.
This is a real,
in real simple terms,
every website is servers and every server can only take so many hits to the
site.
Just say that.
I'm excited that Bravo's here.
It's in the house.
I know Joe.
You know what sucks though,
is that I,
yeah,
but not like your level.
I mean,
and I recently got hacked by x buys a as a guy,
I'm like,
you'd be the on the Bra.
My account on Xbox got hacked.
And what sucks is that that a lot of people are getting hacked on next box and
instead of like Sony playstation who announced it to everybody like,
Hey,
we got hacked in blah blah blah,
x boxes.
Like covering the shit up and like if be go on Twitter,
like I said,
I got hacked in like all these people are like,
so did I,
so did I so dry.
And then you go to Khatak who enjoy steak in,
they're like,
yeah,
that's what they're doing is like in Poland,
people are hacking x boxes and then their fucking adding all these charges.
Like they're,
they're getting all these gamer points and then like using ea has for Fifi
soccer,
they have like these things that they can exchange a points for like these game
cards,
like baseball cards or whatever.
But like there's this whole thing going on.
And the crazy thing is,
is that I told Xbox,
I'm like,
Hey,
I got hacked and they're making this huge,
like,
like I can't go online right now.
I can't do anything right now and can't go online.
No Xbox,
Xbox and,
but listen to this,
I told them three days ago I got hacked and they're still getting,
I'm still getting charges on my,
my checking account.
Uh,
people are still charging,
charging,
charging.
And I told x box,
I'm like,
stop,
take my pay pal,
take my bees.
So take everything off my account and they won't do it.
Why?
Because they want to research who,
where the money's coming from.
So they're using my money.
They're using,
my research is going to reimburse you.
I'm sure they will,
but they're not going to reimburse all the bills that are bouncing right now.
Fuck you.
X Box.
Oh,
ran out of breath
playing your life.
You're really playing on the odds that one out of the 10 fucking Anon don't work
for fun.
I know,
I know.
That's risky.
I wouldn't double down on their,
hey,
you're right.
I know.
Exactly.
There's an inside job going on in Xbox.
I think so.
Do you think some of the incidents,
Jackie,
speaking of my ex's bucks,
she's moving.
Oh,
here's Russell Peters,
standup comedian.
Here's the beautiful thing about drunk.
What do you bond for?
I love it.
I wouldn't want nothing else.
Beautiful thing.
You're perfect.
Don't change.
The beautiful thing about anonymous is that everything's anonymous.
It just like fight club.
There's the people weren't,
man,
this kid's going to get arrested,
but we supposed to not to fucking talk about regionally.
Occasionally people were going to get arrested.
The beauty of anonymous is what it represents is the future of government.
That's what it represents is that the government is going to be,
it's going to be what,
10 [inaudible] who really knows security
politics,
not what I'm saying now listen to what I'm saying.
It represents the will of the people when they're doing something,
when they're takedown,
they're taking down a government website because of the,
the National Defense Authorization Act.
What they're doing is they're essentially making a stand for the people.
They're saying,
listen to the internet does not like this.
And everyone usually gets behind it and then you see it's bills like Sopa get
taken down and you go,
whoa.
You know the Internet has to say the Internet has to say,
and there's people that are extreme miss on the internet and that's what
anonymous is.
Did the craziest soldiers at the front of the line that are willing to do nutty
shit like tapped by the CIA website and they not?
They don't necessarily.
I don't.
It doesn't have to be.
It could be three.
It doesn't matter what they represent as anonymous individuals are the will of
the entire group on the,
on the Internet.
They don't do shit that people hate.
They don't do anonymous,
has never doing shit that people are really mad at.
Now have you ever noticed they get creepy and they put,
you know they call themselves anonymous?
No,
people's personal information online.
That's some Douche bags.
But the reality of the ethics behind the group is that they're trying to take
down corruption.
They're trying to step in and stop shit.
They trying to do pickup where wikileaks got tripped up because there was a
public figure.
Right.
But at what point do you think that,
you know,
they'll kind of curb that as not to become the dictators themselves.
Who is they?
That's the issue.
The issue is who is day?
Lauren is fine.
As long as there's no true organization and it really does represent the people,
then it'll be,
the internet would be truly democratic.
It's like you're saying they may become evil.
Right now they're doing everything for the px.
Right,
right,
right.
Then all of a sudden,
okay,
so fine,
so,
so
let's,
let's take a non right and let's put them in power.
No,
well no one's saying that.
The idea is
the idea is we've got to get to a certain point in time,
we realized it was a global government.
I think we should have anonymous is power.
We should have the Internet be power.
We should have voting online.
We should have everything the Internet is.
I know.
Yeah.
Okay,
so it only takes four fucking dudes to go and change it.
I get that.
I get through,
but who are those three or four dudes?
We got to eliminate the fact that there can ever be three or four dudes that
have access to any we have to kill.
The [inaudible] have to do,
they can never be three or four dudes that have access to anything.
It has to be all transparent.
Once it becomes transparent,
then he can't steal,
then he can't lie.
Then it'd be really simple.
Internet 2.0 you know what it is,
man.
We're all moving into a certain direction with is going to be no secrets.
I think really clear shall inherit.
The information is going to take over and all your ideas about,
you know,
wanting to be wanting to have privacy.
All that bullshit is going to go.
Bye Bye son.
Cause he was going to be no.
Who's who's watching the,
there's going to be no one watching him and everyone's going to have access to
it.
Ultimately it will be complete and total transparency.
Cheers Buddy.
You know,
and I don't know if that's good,
but it's coming.
Fuck that.
Are you kidding?
I can't take that kind of response.
D measy dead dead.
Mizell fizzle.
D music.
Now
that's a new one that he's got a new pet name for her.
If you get drunk enough to get me a phone number,
that's what's going to be on his phone.
No,
no,
no.
We had a shot of crown,
a shot of our minion.
Special 99 and then a cognac.
I'm sorry.
What'd you say?
I don't think my mic first
cut you out.
Sorry.
Did Red Band?
No,
I didn't.
Is that what it is?
You Read Ben Red.
I think red band just started a brown band.
Oh,
Brown band.
You get it.
He farting
conspiracy theorist at all.
Fucking totally owe me a conspiracy theorist.
Oh,
not really.
No,
You are.
I'll buy into this and that,
but no,
not all of it.
Not all of it,
but a lot of it.
None of it.
I question a lot of things like what?
Namely the moon landing.
I don't fucking trust one single bit.
Yeah.
Not One bit.
Trust that moon landing because,
because I met,
I told,
I think I said this once before and one of the,
one of the buckets,
you wait,
wait,
wait.
Well,
no,
no.
Hold on.
Did you see,
hold on us emotionally upset and Neil Armstrong,
God,
stop right there.
Yeah,
but if you going to work enough,
Joe is going to work is if you're saying we were talking about something,
it's like,
no,
he's not a Dj and he got upset.
I'd be like,
motherfucker,
you're not DJ.
You're put in a mix tape and you got aids.
I mean,
oh,
he hit him with the aides
that,
hey listen,
here's the thing.
Whenever someone says something,
it's crazy.
Make lemonade.
If someone says something as crazy as the moon landing didn't happen,
you got to let them talk without interrupting with some fucking emotional shit
about neurons here.
Gotta let him talk.
I have reasons for this now because I wanted to believe that we went to the moon
because I'm a big nerd for space shit.
And like watch all the Hubble footage and the,
and all the shit they send out.
And it excites me to think that there's other shit out there.
And when you look at the space race,
first of all,
it was against Russia at that time and they were trying to beat somebody to
somewhere,
right,
right.
It was a random,
It was exactly a race.
And then I met this two Indian kids after one of my shows in Houston.
Uh,
they were,
uh,
they were basically rocket scientists.
They were studying astrophysicist,
even the people who study,
they were shredding them.
They were cutting those two
people.
They were,
they were astrophysicist is what they were.
And,
and I was,
and I had a watch on that I had bought,
because I'm a fucking donkey I,
and not this one,
but I had a watch on that.
Allegedly,
the face of the watch was made of moon rock.
Yeah.
And it was a limited piece and all kinds of horse float and must be if it's only
fucking from the moon,
right?
Well until your crumb one basically.
And then they smudged it and whatever.
Anyway,
so I was like,
Hey,
uh,
so have we been to the moon in this chick was like,
no reason to lie to me whatsoever.
And she was like,
they said,
we have.
And I'm like,
what does that mean?
And she goes,
they said,
we have.
And I go,
wait,
I don't know what that means.
They said,
we have accents.
I go,
is it possible that we've been to the moon?
She goes,
it's not possible that we've been to the manic.
What do you mean it's not possible?
She goes,
it's impossible to go to the moon.
That because we can't get past the radiation belt,
the radiate,
we can't build a suit that will protect humans from that radiation without their
skin falling off the radiation on the moon?
No,
the van Allen Radiation Belt between,
between,
between the moon and that.
I'm no radiation,
no radiation to expert.
But I've heard it argued that you never pass through the belt and in fact the
belt is like a donut and there's a hole in the center and if you pass through
you can do that.
My issue with it,
the,
my number one issue is that they never did anything to test.
They never even sent a chicken in this space and see if it comes back alive.
No,
no,
no.
Monkeys went into space and then land the Russian.
They,
no one knew.
Like there was like extreme radiation out there and in fact there's a thing
called the operation starfish prime where they actually detonated a nuclear bomb
in the magnetosphere because they were trying to punch a hole through it and it
made it like they made it way more radioactive.
Like they made the,
the van Allen radiation belts,
like more charts.
It doesn't mean they still,
if there was a,
if it is a donut shape,
apparently you can like fly through it,
but I would've liked to have seen someone do it and you know all like a monkey
or something that said it.
There's slingshot around the fucking wound,
there's all that.
And then the Gr,
I had my iPhone in my hand,
she goes,
your iPhone has more technology and then the entire room and NASA did back then.
That's true.
But that doesn't mean that they couldn't make ample calculations.
Even though even though your iPhone,
your iPhone is doing,
is interacting with a graphic user interfaces,
there's a lot of processing going around.
There's,
you know,
there's signals,
it's picking up,
there's a lot of shit going on with that.
They didn't have to do all that.
They,
all they had was numbers,
right?
Well there was the number so they can physically calculated.
However,
all the equipment they had during the space launch was the equivalent of that of
like,
like one 16th of an iPhone in the whole facility.
Not even that.
It wasn't even that.
By the way,
it doesn't matter.
They still could have done it because they did do it without people for sure.
No,
no.
So you know what I'm saying?
The calculations are not that different space.
You just can't send huge,
well that's,
that's the
question is there's really been no evidence they would ever,
they were able to take biological life into space and return it.
There's been no evidence of that and there has been evidence that they really
absolutely cannot predict solar flares and all kinds of crazy shit that happens.
Storms flare up.
Yeah.
They may spark then predict.
A lot of people believe that people did land on the moon,
but that the,
they faked a lot of the footage and one of the reasons for that is they did fake
a lot of footage at NASA.
Like there was some footage from Gemini missions where they were practice
clearly the same images,
exact same images in practice pictures,
you know,
where they're like wearing suits and hung by wires and then they black those
pictures out.
The publicity people did and said,
and these people don't know any better,
you know,
was a a time of really extreme ignorance.
You know,
people didn't have access to information.
And so there's photos of 'em Collins and uh,
Michael Collins and he's a on this and one of the Gemini missions.
He's on this fucking a,
it looks like he's in deep space with the exact same photo,
is him out of practice,
run hanging by wires and it's just date.
Someone got overzealous and they said,
look,
here's a perfect picture.
Why ruin it?
Let's just put it in space.
Tell people was there,
it's not like the guy didn't go to space.
He absolutely did.
Just,
they might not have been able to take such good fucking pictures up there,
you know?
And so they faked a lot of shit.
And so that makes the whole thing fuzzy because you look at it and you go psalms
wrong man,
something's wrong.
What the fuck is wrong?
There's some shit here that's wrong.
The reason why is I think a bunch of the shit we're looking at probably was
taking place in a studio.
A lot of the photographs are probably horseshit.
It doesn't mean they didn't go.
I don't mean to leave like derail and debunk the whole fucking thing,
but do you did with it?
They did or whether they didn't really matter.
It does.
It's fast.
It absolutely Madison has.
I want to
find out if it's possible to pull off a hoax of that magnitude.
You know,
if you look about what the United States had been capable of doing as far as
like getting us into wars under false pretenses,
corruption,
all the bullshit,
you wonder how far it is possible to take it.
We know it's possible to create war gag doubly.
That's,
we got brains.
Arguably that's way crazier than putting someone on the moon.
Arguably,
uh,
letting people,
you know,
figuring out how to trick a gigantic chunk of people to go into another part of
the world and kill people for you seems to be,
if you're going to fake that,
you're going to fake an operation to get into that.
You're going to bullshit your way into that.
That seems like the moon landing.
It's like,
it's like nothing.
It's nothing in comparison.
Yeah,
cause you can't,
you can't prove,
I didn't even see this shit coming when I came here today.
See,
honestly,
moon landing shit wasn't real,
was it not?
I was not in the back of my mind.
It wasn't in mine,
but I forgot the Russells of Mungai.
Look,
I,
I've,
I've argued with people and I absolutely don't know.
I don't know.
I don't,
I don't believe you are totally down for you or the moon hoax crusade or no,
no,
no.
Listen,
listen,
man.
Here's my issue.
My issue is how can I even argue it?
How is it possible that I even have points?
How is it possible that anybody had ever heard of the moons?
You see breezy right there,
fucking all this shit.
I hope someone did go to the moon.
I hope someone did.
I really do.
I don't know if they didn't,
but I do know that it's weird that it's the only time in human history where
people have been more than 400 feet above the earth's surface.
No other space shuttle mission,
no other space station mission.
Nothing goes any higher than that.
That's it.
But they went 260,000 miles out and then return to earth man when they did in
1969 to 1972 I know if I had a boss,
a bit of a head fuck,
can't do it now.
We haven't,
haven't had flux.
It's a bit of a head fuck now when they talk about going to the moon,
George W.
Bush,
why do that lady,
why don't,
why don't we just released like a two k 13 edition of going to the moon and
back?
Well,
you know you do a of the day,
first of all,
he can't.
They say the,
our technology is much more improved now,
so they would have to read easier,
can't you would say so they can't use the Saturn five rockets though because
that's like an old model.
They don't want to just recreate what worked in the 60s they want to apply
modern technology and a printer and then now might've monitoring too fucked up.
Playing devil's advocate to the extreme here,
I never pretended I,
I don't know what the fuck happened.
Wouldn't mind
fucking artists to perform on the moon.
It would be pretty dope if we could actually go to the moon if it was safe.
You know,
I don't know
if you've seen the photos that they had that they had a lunar rover orbiter to
took photos,
whatever the fuck it was.
The Mars orbiter.
Now they took photos of the moon and they showed like the little spots where the
astronauts were walking like fair footprints fucking way in 50 eggs.
It looks fake as fuck.
Like what the footprints are you still there,
Shannon?
Romain agnostic to do to the whole.
I do too.
I would think it would be hilarious though,
is if,
even if we actually did go to the moon,
if some overzealous NASA fucking freak said,
listen,
these hoaxers who got to fucking show them,
I'm going to show a nonpartisan.
Yeah.
Third parties.
It's gotta be a third party.
Can't be a third party because he won't let anybody go anywhere near the sites.
There's,
they've declared a ban on flyovers of all the moons sites.
This is true because they don't want to disturb the area.
This is absolutely true.
Obama's pastor,
so the optics Sadat allowed the other countries like India,
go see a picture of that epic landing spot.
Can't go there.
You can't fly over and take a picture
that seems suspect a little bit.
It does a little bit.
You know,
I look,
I've argued with it.
I don't,
I've argued with this Guy Phil plait from bad astronomy.com and he's a great guy
and I really wished I didn't have to argue with them cause I love,
I love so much of the Shitty says like I love his,
his speeches.
He did a Ted talk on asteroids.
It was fucking awesome what did meet you?
But it was his problem with me.
It's,
they're so proud about it,
man.
I didn't talk to him about it.
Is that,
how funny is that?
What are the greatest theoretical physicists in the world guys?
An idiot.
That's awesome.
That was awesome.
You know?
Um,
I think it's a major fucking guy.
Just a silly to me right now.
He's like,
dude,
you remember we got the Grammy's smile at night.
I'm like,
dude,
I got it.
We good?
Is he in the guy on the couch texted to fuck.
He's going to text you while it shows going on.
You can actually like come over here and fucking tapped me on the shoulder.
How dare here,
but I'm going to text him back.
I'm asleep.
I'm good.
Wait to go captain corporate.
Thanks Dean.
Isn't it funny you have like some babysitter?
I do.
I hear a grown man.
Well I can.
That's ridiculous.
You're skinny enough to not have to worry about looking puffy in the morning.
Why are you worried about this tow that guy to go to sleep?
It was ridiculous.
That two hot chicks beside him.
Why does your,
does your manager normally do this?
D come here,
come here dean.
This is ridiculous behavior.
No Dean come here right now because that was my manager I blocked.
You know how to call a cab the fuck bro.
He doesn't want to come over.
What are,
you know Joe and sue,
that Guy Breezy.
He's really smart with this fucking space.
Shit.
Dean,
come here.
Come here.
Fuck Dean.
Dean come.
Unless you want me to like drastically renegotiate my management contract.
I really think it's in your best interest that you come here.
Come here dean to dean.
Dean.
Better yet have on you
diamond rings.
That's this guy right here.
Come on.
Oh,
he can talk from there.
Dean has an English accent.
Did you find him in Liverpool?
No,
actually I found them in Kent,
which don't call him a cat.
It can avoid saying you fucking can't.
There's,
they'll call it an accident in the world in English.
In my opinion,
those Guy Richie,
I really walk and love those.
Do you know why they get the getaway?
That's why.
Do you have that camera?
Can I
guide where she made a movie a year?
It would be very happy
cow shit over there on the right.
Yeah,
I did.
Somebody come here,
I'll do a night vision.
No,
no.
Just painting.
It was one of the odd dude.
He doesn't want it to be on.
Let's just say shit.
Why you are so into I have anything.
No more alcohol for dads was,
see there he is right there.
Right there.
You're like a van Halen on Dean Howard.
Dean says Dean Dean this let this be a lesson to not be texting me and telling
them what to do.
He says he doesn't like that shit shade.
We gotta be Outta here at nine in the morning so don't get too wasted or are you
going to do the Grammy's,
the Grammy's or small for me there at nine in the morning cause I got to go do
another run through with the foo fighters.
Yeah,
but dude,
it's only one 40 what's though?
I got it.
When did you get got it?
I've been doing this for a while.
I know how to hit a space bar.
Yeah,
I really do.
Fucking today shit up fucking guy.
He knows,
you know.
Yeah,
no,
it's really cool.
We're,
we're doing this like really crazy
cool shit with the foo fighters,
which is amazing.
Um,
because they basically gave me like a,
like a,
you know,
when you go to a hotel,
you got like a shit fucking after night,
like service menu.
Yes.
Margarito or tuna melt or something bullshit.
You know what I mean?
That's kind of what they offered me,
you know.
And uh,
at the end of the day there was something I really wanted,
you know,
and they said,
well,
in order to perform on the Grammy's you have to perform as someone who's also
nominated and all that stuff.
And uh,
the foo fighters were,
and I had recently done a remix for the foo fighters.
Ah,
shit,
this is my saving grace.
I don't have to like get like pigeonholed with this like Edm segregation from
the Grammy's,
cause it almost like it's still early according to,
you know,
pop culture and United States and all that surrounds us.
The A's.
Yeah.
So it's gonna always going to be that like sideshow thing and a tent outside of
the big main show,
you know?
And they were like,
well,
who you want to perform with and here's your list of options,
you know,
so it's like the late night room service menu,
I don't know what I want,
you know,
but I had done a collaboration with the fuse foods in the past.
Is that what you call the foo fighters?
You look really deep inside that you can call them the foods.
You're really in there when you really,
yeah,
he really is.
Who's baby?
Let me call you.
Can I call you guys foods?
You were right.
They were traumatic tonight.
Yeah,
he's definitely tough.
That whole,
the whole day
thing was cool,
you know?
And we had done this really big long European run where,
you know,
basically rock group is playing across the stage from where I was playing at the
same time.
So of course Dave's always like,
oh fuck you know,
computers and all this and there's real rock and roll and then you know,
and they play.
And then I'd be playing it at the same time and all this stuff.
And
like you were competing pretty
much pretty much for like,
and how big is this place where you're playing in?
Oh,
Puco pop or about 160,000 strong.
Okay.
So there's competing signals.
So there's like your,
your sound is coming from one side,
his age and his friend the other.
Yeah,
you bunny.
It was absolutely amazing and it was such a terror because it was like,
you know,
because the Edm thing and the whole movement you want cross you and Edm,
electronic dance music and I guess what the kids like to call these days.
You used to call it euro trash bag,
right?
Well now we still do.
Yeah.
How did it evolve in Europe?
What happened then?
Well,
it started right?
House music started in Chicago.
Well they say technically Detroit,
Detroit,
Detroit.
Then it moved to Chicago and Kraftwerk got good.
And then,
oh Kraftwerk yet true.
Troy,
Kraftwerk was kind of like the groundwork for like the,
for like a planet rock and all the hip hop shit.
And then,
and then house music started in like [inaudible] 82 83 with Steve Silk Hurley.
Would you agree with that,
Jack?
Your body at all?
Pete is dropping
a little bit and then in around 1989 90 is when Europe got ahold of it and then
that's when it started to really take a shit is because the white Europeans
would like,
this is too fucking smooth and mellow and then they would add the,
we are a wow.
Wow,
wow,
wow.
That's when acid house and fucking hip house and all this shit started and
that's when I was like,
what are you doing to this fucking great house music and then it would like
been around.
Wow.
I won't be around.
Where's my sampler when I met?
Oh,
why?
I have a nice hot heaters,
so much more about music and macular hole to disco 2.0 brilliant.
It was,
yeah,
it was.
It was electronic.
Disco is whatever.
What I'll tell you what man,
every now and then someone will play this Saturday night fever soundtrack and I
go,
God damn is some good fucking jams in that song on that track or that CD and not
a woman.
It's true.
Just some tremendous songs.
If you could just put yourself back in the mindset of the people that were lit
alive.
She was the day it was the shit sign.
The fucking beat done some harmonies.
It's ever hit.
All of that shit.
They were singing like France nerd Fulan who was the,
who can tell by the way that I use my walker door.
They Samaranch pitches.
Yeah.
I in the call center was amazing.
I dance,
I dance to,
I can't have you if I can't have you in second grade or grade two as we know it.
That stuff was the second grade I audition was,
might not hold up in my talent show with like if I can ask you Yvonne Element
interesting fact about Yvonne Element,
the first Filipino singer.
Really?
Wow.
Why was singing that in bodies,
that song though to body.
She also sang Wang,
uh,
that song and Jesus Christ superstar.
Oh Wow.
Who Do you think you are?
No.
What was that song,
uh,
in,
sorry.
I was the fuck was it called a
damn.
I was in the metal.
I wasn't in the end of that disco shit,
man.
I've always loved,
I've always loved all kinds of music.
I love disco.
I was a kid,
I was a huge kiss kiss in 82 on the last two with makeup and the F and ps three.
And the reason I turned that in the first tour without makeup,
it was the same.
It was the same tank.
Remember I talk kiss this year for the first time last year.
The Gardens?
Yeah,
it was the same tank.
Did they blow shit up with the raking one speaker blew out.
I saw them when I was kid and I met ace freely without his makeup when I was
like eight years old,
a gun in his skin was
full makeup like in the whole thing and everything raise crazy pock marks on his
face.
French fries.
I was like,
when I was a kid,
my uncle worked for Howard marks advertising,
which was the company that used to make the album covers.
Fosters,
no,
it wasn't a Manhattan and uh,
yeah,
my uncle and his friend.
Yeah,
my uncle and his friend Dennis Dude.
I used to.
So my uncle used to make,
I checked,
they used to make these album covers.
You'll let us,
Eddie,
uh,
Peter Criss and uh,
Gene Simmons,
all his guys would stop by and I was a,
I was there with him one day at world my friend.
All right.
Forget having a cover.
Right.
I'm listening to,
I think that's amazing.
There's no more stories to be told.
I think that's awesome.
I think that's a unique story that no one knows.
We missed it.
Yeah.
You missed it.
And then you were talking over me.
You know,
gene gene was at the Improv a couple of weeks ago with Shannon and I happened to
be on that night and gene did a gene did a quote from my book that was released
in Canada.
Oh really?
Wow.
And he didn't even fucking know he did it.
No,
no.
Like for the back of the book it was like,
Oh,
Russell is a,
is a very handsome man.
Aye.
I imagine he would be very popular in Israel is what the quote was.
I wonder about that sometimes.
What am I going to do when I get in fucking jail?
Jail.
I have no plans on being in jail.
Dead mouse and drink
red band.
Ben Over here brought up an interesting fucking point.
As a matter of fact,
he said,
dude,
have you ever seen any prison tattoos?
And I'm like,
whoa.
No,
not really.
Like you know the fucking bag that Henning there.
I thought and I thought for a minute we'll wait a minute.
What if I do some like dodgy thing that does actually end me up in fucking jail?
Am I going to be like someone's bitch or am I going to be,
oh dude,
that's that mouse.
You better hope it's metro west a little bit.
Yeah,
right.
Yeah.
Well let me know like I guess the Safeway we'd be going,
it's just don't do anything that would warrant you being in jail.
Pay Your taxes and don't fuck people.
Right?
Yeah.
Okay,
cool.
I can do more with Eddie and joke.
No more rape for you.
Yeah,
I might be a bitch.
I think I wouldn't be like in general if I were to
come across the fucking place right now.
It's a lot of talking over and buy some.
It's a lie talking room.
Sorry.
There's a lot of drunk going on in this room.
No,
there's no,
no,
no.
There's a lot of talking over everybody cause everybody's drunk.
No,
it's a fucking mediator.
I'm sorry.
Continued.
No,
I'm just saying it is true drastically.
Now.
How often do you do podcasts?
Podcasts?
This is my first one.
I'm birds and it's just like when you went,
when I know we're all having a conversation.
If we were all hanging out and smoking weed and drinking,
we'd have a conversation.
It would be a lot like this cluster fuck between four guys less the smoking will
we have for you,
for you,
for ways for Eddie and I,
it would be twice as much.
We'd so we'd bounce you out anyway.
We would be able to hear each other talk.
Right.
You know,
that's what you got to do with a podcast.
You've got to be cognizant and other people were talking at the same time.
What,
Hey Joel,
have you ever had an eight?
What was your favorite show that you've ever done that,
but we broke it so you'd have like a concert fix it.
Do you have a concert that is like,
do you have a content?
Like you're your most memorable?
Do you have like something that you always think of?
Like that was the best time I ever had at a show.
Like that was the one show that,
that,
that blew all the others out of the water.
Shit.
That dude.
Yeah.
I mean I don't,
because he knew I could say anything right now.
It would only pertain to that group and then that would be gospel.
Right.
And that's fucked up.
But you do have one in your head and you just don't want it.
No,
I'm,
I'm thinking right now.
Well,
you know what?
Anytime in red rocks,
whenever I put play at restaurants,
amazing place ever,
right?
Absolutely is.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Red Rocks.
Did you notice outside of Denver?
It's carved into a side of a mountain.
It's like an amphitheater and it,
dude,
you're playing between two fucking mountain.
It's so dope.
Crazy.
And the,
when you look at the audience
says that because the each like,
I don't know why you say it like,
like a rung or a stand of where the audience stands.
It's like four feet.
So you're,
you're not looking at like this kind of like,
you know this vanishing point of people you're looking at this wall,
right?
You know of fucking just crazy dude.
They do comedy there.
They do comedy and they have movies there.
Red Rocks.
No Shit.
Red Rocks is amazing and there's a high possibility you might see a mountain
lion can't you might,
you might say,
you know,
you can't wander off to pis in the woods,
bro.
You like,
Hey Jack,
it's a possibility.
It's not a good possibility,
but it's out there.
What percentage of people at your shows a rough estimate are on ecstasy?
Rough estimate.
Yes.
90 90%
right?
I won't honestly,
the really couch behind you before you answer this,
you're manager sweating right now.
Make the corporate anything stupid.
Shaw.
No.
Really?
Cds might make a comeback.
I take 30%
Joe.
You know why?
You know why
50 of them are on Molly because they know better because like the Internet,
Molly,
how did that name come about anyway?
Because it's a tell us,
you know,
I don't know how Demali come about.
I know I've only been recently hearing about this in the last two years.
It's ecstasy cause usually ecstasies like cut with other bullshit I have to do
with Molly cause it's true in,
what's it called?
MDM.
A MTMA Lawley methylene and dioxin.
Methylamphetamine nicknamed MD
made in a laboratory site like,
like ecstasy.
Hard to be like some scientific chemical bullshit.
I only stop that until a month ago.
I saw a documentary on ecstasy and Mtma the pure form.
It's just like coke.
We're coke all comes from the south,
South America.
All ecstasy comes from these rare,
uh,
the roots of these rare trees in Cambodia
comes from Cambodia
to take you seriously.
I supposed to take you seriously when you come to a fucking concert to
appreciate music and craft and art and all that stuff.
If you're like on these mind altering substances,
come on man.
That's what it sounds like.
You're supposed to be taking them seriously.
But it is kind of fascinating that if you ever see current current TV they have,
or vanguard,
that's the name of the show.
There's a,
I think that's untrue TV or one of the,
one of those TV networks were secure cable network and they uh,
they,
they spend a lot of time and the,
there's the in the woods where these people are like,
there's like a lot of like serious crime going on because people are cutting
down these trees.
They find these accuracy labs out in the woods and they go in with guns and it's
crazy.
The military comes in.
It's really nuts,
man.
It's just like Columbia.
I didn't know.
I didn't know either.
I thought it was a,
I thought it was the same thing that you thought.
I thought it was some shit mate in the lab.
So is this like something generally accepted that should go in hand in hand with
like electronic music then?
No.
Y'All listen man,
I think you're taking it really personal.
I don't think it has to,
we're just tripping out on what it is.
We're just tripping out on what it is
that you're right in the same frequency of trans to them.
It's crazy and therefore you their mouse.
That's very crazy way hold the music that he makes his act and I'm a fucking
cynic and a big ass critic.
No Shit.
But,
but his music is
actually not on that level of e because it's actually mellow smooth house to me
like him and cascade.
I may not appreciate them as Djs per se,
but as artists I go,
fuck yeah,
that shit is dope.
Well,
you know,
having said that,
I'm going to fucking crusader.
I'm not,
I'm not tailoring.
No,
but I mean,
but I'm saying like the shit you'd make is not like shit that people need to be
high for.
No,
not at [inaudible] level with all of your hard drive in my life.
You never done heart drug ever.
I've never,
never done mushrooms.
No.
Have you done dude?
Name it off.
I can tell you salvia acid,
nothing.
A bit of pot.
When I was fucking kid.
I'm same way.
I've tried weed and didn't like,
and that was it for me.
That was all I needed to see your smoke me right.
Fucking now I guarantee you,
which would be in the fucking bathroom shaking and every time that fucking door
opens easy,
they're going to be a cop or my mom.
Wow.
Or your mom as a cop or my mom's dress up fucking God.
Exactly.
That's cool.
That's kind of cool.
It's Kinda cool.
But I also almost want to get it like a sex change and just so I could spoon you
and do mushrooms with you,
you know what I mean?
Comfort you and like take you through the desert
desert.
That's hilarious.
No,
you know what I mean though?
Like I want to comfort him
planet.
Besides,
you would have explained it that way.
I don't have a sex change and I want to spoon,
you know,
I just want to like hold them.
I just want to like nurse him into mushrooms.
Attitude needs a nurse.
He needs,
he needs muscles,
he needs,
he needs marijuana.
He needs something.
I bet you if he does that though,
the Grammy's with blow up.
They would fucking bleed on the couch at spot when they're in the bed that you
don't think would be be easier to talk to?
No,
no.
I think,
I think what he does is the most amazing shit ever in the whole entire road.
And I can't even believe he doesn't fuck wait about more than heart surgery.
I really,
I really appreciate musicians I have.
No matter if you is is I presume,
I mean and like I've listened to him a million times.
The first time I met Veronica can Ricci,
the first time I met Veronica reach you,
I made this whole video because we went to a a org orchard or an orchid.
Uh,
what would that orange and orange grove orchard.
We went to an orange grove and I made a video and I picked out a dead mouse
song,
a dead mouse of song to put as the soundtrack because I think that is an amazing
song and I met somebody amazing and I put this song,
no,
fuck you.
But in a special moment in your life right now.
No,
no,
no.
I feel like I'm here.
All right.
This case.
It sounds as good as it sounds.
That's what I liked.
Gandalf's how's the opposite?
Did
the music music to me is so insane to me.
It's is,
hold on.
His music's one of the most important things in life.
It's what I'm saying and I think it's amazing.
Meaning somebody that I listened to and I fucking have had like emotions with,
I fucking had trips with.
I've had a fucking really cool evenings with listening to somebody I don't even
know and I get to meet the person that designed that
suck his dick.
Come on to me.
Yeah,
I have a brother habit.
All right.
You've done the beam to flush on a pice.
Preemptive 40 aim to flush [inaudible] you've got it and you're like,
I got this.
And then you like time it so that you hit the fucking flusher as it is.
Right?
This is done this a little not quite there yet and it goes viral or it's just
flush it again.
You want to flush it.
You're like,
no,
wait bro.
You know you're probably going to go 30 seconds.
We know it's a weird obsession.
The one that like piss into clean water.
I hate this shit and I believed him and then I flushed and I got to piss again
right after.
What does that,
that's where it's my Dick not coordinating with my ass.
Low Communication.
Then there was also a good thing on the side note.
So Peter's dropping bombs bitches.
You thought this show was getting bored.
The conflict with steer us off the tracks and into the woods we bought.
Determine that you need some sort of psychedelics young man.
You're a very nice guy,
but you definitely need something.
Weed,
pot,
something.
Somebody needs to sit you down.
He,
I don't think he needs anything because I'm a clean right.
I don't know.
Just calm me down.
So I'm an alcoholic guy.
That'd be a little perspective.
I think he's doing everything right right now.
Don't
wait till he's fucking 70 or 80 and then do my showrooms 70 or 80 and to do
mushrooms.
I Dunno.
I'll wait until
you're not in accordance to law right now.
If I were to do some crazy shit.
Right.
I'm easily susceptible just getting into porn.
Oh right.
Cause you're Canadian,
the Canadian thing.
Ah,
that's so true.
even
nervous about the OT because it's true.
I was baffled.
I was like,
this doesn't make no,
I don't think that's what it is,
man.
I think we just hasn't had that many positive experiences and he's a very
positive person and he's ambitious and he's obviously to go from where you
started doing that kind of music and then four years later you're filling the
Roger Center.
You have to be ambitious.
There's no way around
back and in terms of fucking doing shit then fine
fucking smoking weed and all that shit right now.
Are you kidding me dude?
Like I'm just so preoccupied with fucking this,
that and the other thing.
I know,
I understand that.
But you're drinking.
That's what doesn't make any sense.
You're altering your state.
You're,
you're altering.
Your state is different.
It's a different alteration.
Yeah.
It's the Shitty,
shitty or what I'm comfortable with the one that benefits you,
at least it's the one that gives you the,
the balls,
blackouts.
It gives you the most to her.
It allows you to like relax your standards.
It allows you to come here and get some work on that.
Let you ego flight shortly.
It's true.
It's definitely,
you know the is absolutely true though.
We didn't work for me.
I prefer alcohol
drinking off.
I'm going to call you both.
I believe you,
but who did you get high with it?
It wasn't even who I got high with.
Its high.
How much?
I just tried it every time I tried it.
I did not like the like the way I feel paranoid,
not even parent.
I got bored and I've got add so it didn't fuck.
There's absolutely two different kinds of weed though.
Do you know that most of the people,
what most people get,
it's called Endeca and what indicators is couch weed makes you really sleepy and
tired.
There's another thing called Sativa South American.
We'd like South Pacific,
so that's like,
it's from the a parts of the world and it's way different.
No,
no.
I think he's thinking that the Salvia divinorum Oh yeah,
this is sativa,
sativa,
Sativa,
road.
Marijuana.
Yes.
It's a different,
it's,
it's a,
it's a much more heady,
much more Carl Sagan.
Much more staring at fucking documentaries sativa.
Right.
Much more like,
you know what I'm saying is that I do that.
Most people don't know that.
I know you do.
I know you do,
but there is totally to totally different effects.
Eddie likes it all.
He doesn't give a fuck.
I think it's all good
right away.
I started to Moria anyway.
I agree with that as well.
Especially once you're a seasoned smoker.
No,
no,
no.
It's not the same shit.
No,
it's definitely not start smoking till I don't think it is,
man.
I don't think it has the same effect.
It's anything that has the same effect.
I used to really think that sativa like controlled your appetite and Endeca.
You got the munchies and all that shit.
I think it's whatever you think it is.
That's right.
Whoa.
I kind of see that because I've been doing a lot of hybrids lately.
You guys are what's known as stoners?
No,
no,
no.
I've been doing a lot of hybrids lately and then this one time I soon got hybrid
and then I was like,
this is the best week.
That perfect blend of both.
And then I'm like,
oh wait,
this is [inaudible] on the bottle.
This whole time I've been doing Endeca.
So it's like,
I'm almost like,
all right,
is this like fucking Alpha brain and Mike,
like what?
You know,
like what am I doing?
Is it a placebo?
Yeah.
Hmm.
I think you're all crazy.
You were smoking airborne.
Maybe.
Maybe this motherfucker's lost too much weight.
Only done good for me.
So
first time I had fucking smoke pot.
Was it upstage a,
a radio show that was actually being syndicated?
A one oh nine
or one energy energy.
Is that a Toronto station?
Yeah,
it is a total was Burlington.
Do you remember the uh,
the daily planet
from Niagara Falls?
Oh,
it was that kind of fear from Saint Catharines.
So you're going to have an Agora pause here from Niagara Falls.
Yeah.
Slow down.
What else do you like waterfalls?
Are you guys like gang members?
So we had this,
we had this radio show and there was a guy there,
DJ,
just nice.
And he would come in and we would do,
yeah,
just nice.
Like,
hey dude,
dude,
this dude's would show up.
But like these like amp bag full of fucking weed
back,
they said an ANP back.
You know what?
It made me happier if you'd said a food city bag you guys,
it's crazy.
I swear to God.
I was about 1819 years old.
How old do you know like holy,
I'm 31 easy,
slow down midlines kids 31 so they would smoke a joint and the first time I
actually smoked a proper fucking blunt.
I Shit you not.
It was did this like rap song and I don't know what it was,
but I know the lyric because I was so stoned and I kept hearing the same lyric
lyric over and over and over again.
It was like,
I don't want to something man.
I don't want to chill.
I just want to see my head up on a $100 bill.
I don't want to l I just want to chill my hand.
The $100 bill it dude that and owed me bulldogs.
Well bloods or a different experience because you know,
ironically a friend of mine also from Boston at Oji blunts or different
experience because you have probably have that on my phone right now.
But no,
honestly when I was up in,
uh,
up on top of this computer store and you know,
recording this fucking show dude,
I was like passed out fucking staring at the ceiling and hearing the same lyric
over and over again and every day
Tom the door.
Yeah,
that's the one.
It was just playing over and over and over in the head.
And every time that the security thing went off at the door,
that opened up and like I said,
it was either a cop or my mom or my mom dressed up as a cop.
You need a sample that a new,
it was fuck,
come on.
It's perfect.
That's when I decided,
you know what,
not for everyone.
That sounds like a,
like a senior,
a Stanley Kubrick movie or you need to grab that shit.
Mom dressed up like a jazzy Jeff juggling it before the fucking chorus comes in.
Hold on a sec.
Shit.
Monahan
wanted shit out Monahan.
Can we do this?
One of the hill?
Ain't no,
they're running harder to jazzy Jeff is juggling and back and forth.
That's a very specific accent.
I would say that the Philadelphia,
yeah,
I think it played out.
Is that legal?
Is that a Philadelphia accent?
Oh,
it's Boston.
Is it really?
That's interesting.
Boston,
Philadelphia,
Andrew saw,
oh,
we were fade outs.
Joe,
you're from fucking Boston.
Don't like that.
Yeah,
it doesn't,
it sounded like Philadelphia to me.
But Boston black is very different than Boston white.
There's this does it different accents.
Like there's a lot of the pack your car that didn't get inherited by the Boston
black community.
Like that's like they were Teresa Neal was a black guy.
Marijuana,
brilliant comedian from Boston.
He didn't have the Boston accent,
you know,
Westin.
I put Teresa would use what you used to say,
the fucking dumbest shit to each other one.
I remember we were in,
in Scotland in 2000 and he had this girlfriend at the time who was from
Liverpool and uh,
she,
we were walking and everything was fucking uphill in Scotland in Edinburgh.
And,
uh,
she was complaining about walking and goes,
bitch,
don't act like you're too fucking high post to be walking up and down.
And I just thought it was the funniest shit because she said that and adding
color.
He called her high posts,
remember all yeah.
And I was like,
I can't remember the cabaret fucking Voltaire or what we were at the Edinburgh
comedy festival.
Oh Shit.
And I just remember thinking,
I kept saying by the castle,
it was by the cast.
So we were on North Castle Street.
Okay,
okay.
Okay.
And I would just,
I would just even years later I would say to him,
I go,
hey you acting all fucking high hypo.
Cause there was a song called high post at that time to post high.
When was this?
He had the two.
All right.
Teresa band raising shit.
I'm banned from a place on fucking castle or the cabaret Voltaire.
I was what did you do to them?
Well I didn't do anything.
I was testing the integrity of a bottle outside of the nightclub,
basically kicking it against a care of seeing how much it would take to smash.
And so it's funny cause that was odd,
segregate
the official and whatever.
But I was playing at the club that night and then we stopped or whatever and now
I'm out of town and having a cigarette and I'm like kind of edge and a bottle on
the fucking thing.
Cause everyone was like smashing bottles.
It's fucking Edinburgh.
So I'm going crazy fucking whatever.
And I start like,
like Kinda like back kicking this fucking bottle on their thing and all the
security guys are watching me waiting for the fucking thing to break.
Cause they knew as soon as it breaks it had grounds to fucking kicked me out and
he had a weapon or something.
So then they had evidence that you're a Douche bag.
Yeah.
So I finally broke it and then they all came out and they say,
okay listen,
here's your shit,
here's your whatever.
Like you're not welcome here.
I mean we're,
we're abandoning you.
But it was really funny because it was like totally secret Amanda moment where
they were like,
we're banishing you,
you are banished,
you're banished and you're like totally banished from this nightclub.
And I'm like,
okay,
all right,
that's cool.
Yeah,
it,
it's fine.
Whatever.
Just give me my jacket and I'll go.
And it was funny because I really didn't put up a fight at all.
I was just like,
Whoa,
hold on a second man.
If you were running a club,
would you want some guy breaking bottles out?
Well,
yeah,
exactly.
That's why I played along and I'm like,
okay,
you know what?
I know what I did was stupid and Douchey and I,
you know,
I accept the banishment and I'll take it and I'll go.
And they were like,
okay,
just so you know your band.
I'm like,
okay,
give me my jacket.
And the incident,
they gave him up my jacket and they started to like kind of walk me out of that
little front row pros and they would like,
just so you know your Ben.
I'm like,
yeah,
I get it.
I'm bad,
I'm bad.
I'm never allowed to or ever again.
Right.
Is that what you mean by banish?
And they were like,
yes,
here's your tracking.
You don't get out of here bag.
What we're trying to tell you is that you are never,
ever,
ever allowed here again.
And I'm like,
okay,
yeah.
And they're like,
no.
I'm like,
when never allowed to getting dude.
He just went on.
When clubs think that they're way more,
it was crazy dude.
And I'm like,
okay,
listen,
if I can get kicked out of a club and fucking that a burrow and never go back
again,
and my aunt's going to regret this later in life,
probably not.
So I just accepted it.
Never know.
Dawn really didn't like that might be the spot.
I'm sure I know you one day.
Fraud going.
Come on man.
I'm sorry.
Listen,
I know what he's done is wrong.
I mean up all your bottles today,
they pull up the list of,
but it was really funny.
So,
so like I'm banished from this club and I'm outside on the sidewalk like across
the street,
like almost at the completely different fucking venue.
And they kept having people come out of the place that I was banished from.
[inaudible] were saying,
dude,
your band.
And I'm like,
okay,
I get it.
That's all right.
Okay.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
no,
wait a minute.
Hold on.
They banned you,
so you went across the street and the Hubbard.
Yeah,
yeah,
because I'm like waiting.
They're essentially trying to get you to get the fuck out of there.
Like,
like out of their whole country.
Well,
they wanted you to get out of their view.
They tried to kick,
he kicked you out of Bactrim and then you went across the street and just to
stare them.
Was that essentially what happened?
Is Stereo room stared at them staring at Oh,
no,
no.
I was on my way out.
Like we were ready to get on one of those.
What did the call break Shaw's where they got the Bible.
Oh,
so you're just waiting to pick you up.
Yeah,
I'm just waiting for,
you know,
management.
It's so funny because they just made a really,
really huge effort to have everyone come out and saw your band,
your band.
I guess for them it's like,
hey,
as a local scene,
it's like a fucking devastating hit,
you know,
if you're a local band,
oh yeah.
That would suck.
That'd be devastating.
It was a one shot on how often he got.
I mean there's always like shit bees.
Does that ever happen to the Toronto comedy scene?
Guys get banned from fuck yeah,
I was banned from Niagara Square.
Start Holding [inaudible] Russell Peters speak for a second please.
In Toronto.
In Canada,
especially if you work for Yucky x are not allowed to perform it.
Any other,
no shit that happens.
There's,
there's so,
it's funny cause the young comics like that.
I know still in Toronto we'll call me like,
Yo,
I'm thinking about leaving Yuk Yuk.
She's like,
I'm going to call them.
I'm like,
don't fuck if you're going to leave a bitch,
don't fucking tell her you leaving and just fucking bounce and let the hook her
figure it out on her own.
Wow.
Russell Peters with some chrome pimp hand type shit back knuckled knocking
pitches for a loop and
world as the bitch [inaudible] you're okay.
You're out of if you're out of Yucky x,
you're working for the outside as they call it.
The banished young says good rooms.
They have a bunch of don't have the great rooms and then here's the problem.
The one in Vancouver was amazing,
but they don't have right.
That's gone now.
Right?
Well they,
they mix.
Here's the thing,
they were always good to me,
but,
but that's because they never really fell for,
I'm your whole fucking mentality.
You know what I mean?
I would leave,
let a motherfucker know,
you know,
to gain from 95 from [inaudible] 95 I started going
to show up with a cane,
got a real lamp.
Let them know,
son,
let him know.
Tell him why you met Joe.
Tell Him Barnabas Collins head on at a big silver dragon.
I started playing outside of Yuck kicks in in 95 like in England and I realized
that the rest of the world was there that I didn't need to fucking focus on
Canada like that.
Didn't you like really get famous very quickly because of the Internet?
Because of video clips?
Well,
not really quick.
I mean,
I don't want to say like I was 15 years in when I got home.
I started in 89 oh,
I didn't know that in Canada was around since 89 it was like eight he was
probably eight years now.
It was a was eight when I started.
That's amazing.
Did you did,
but you became famous as far as I am my world because the Internet,
that is absolutely correct.
A bunch of people sending me clips were like,
have you heard this Russell Peters guy?
And then boom,
like youtube clips,
like you are one of the first guys that I know that really blew up because of
youtube.
That was in oh four late oh four when youtube just started and then by the time
the end of oh five came,
I literally went from making $40,000 a year to [inaudible] the end of o three a
to the end of o for making half a million.
No,
no,
but I'm saying like like that's what it went for.
$40 to know they're going to ask 30,000 to half a million in like in a year like
that.
Well,
let's stop your progress right now.
Not Catch up to today because people are going to get sad.
No,
no.
Now I'm broke and that's why I'm here.
How are being sad like that?
I mean sad about their own lives.
When was the last time you were at the Olive Garden?
Fucking,
let me tell you something.
I fucking love the olive garden.
Fuck you mother.
Last time.
Seriously,
one of the last time Russell Peters is that November leave.
You snuck that in November.
I was at the Holiday Times Square.
Oh,
that's the good one.
That was the nation's capitol.
That's the hotspot.
Olive Garden.
There's lines to get into this all together was I was me Dj spin bad.
His wife and his two kids.
Did you get in like did you like,
I'm rocking it enough like that.
Don't shut that shit.
Don't work at the olive garden fool.
She got [inaudible] little thing you put in your pocket that gives along the
lines,
the CD,
disk sized fucking vibrator that they give you.
You know it's the worst and it lights the light.
You know it's the worst.
This is the worst thing.
Si true story that that that thing,
if you go out of bounds at the Burbank Olive Garden,
always an hour and a half to two hour wait.
So if you go out of bounds it starts playing this really embarrassing song and
it won't stop.
So like I would always go do your thing you're talking about,
I would go to target and next thing you know he'd start playing nursery rhymes
but really loud and it's like,
it's like an ice cream truck in your pocket looking at you and it's like,
it's like you're,
yeah,
I swear to God and it's like a way to say,
hey,
you're stealing something.
You're stealing the olive garden's property.
We're going to annoy everybody
around you by this really high pitched nursery.
Ryan give you,
I guess as long as it's 10 that it's torturing you.
Whereas if it was like an alarm that went off like right,
he'd probably sue them for that shit.
Right?
Like,
how do I get this to shut off so they can't like put like some audio that's like
stolen property now they played a nice happy song like hey you should have
hands.
They should have like an old tango.
Hey what are you doing with them?
My pay,
I went to the supermarket
bag,
I went to the supermarket the other day and as I'm leaving the supermarket,
the the wheels on my cart lock up.
Oh yeah.
They had a certain distance where you could travel away from the store before
the car locked up.
But this was so fucking stupid cause it was right in front of this.
I do that with my house
mouse ears that we sell at.
The show is actually owned by these little like kind of headband mouse ears.
And if you actually walk out 50 feet of the venue then you're shocked.
Are you serious?
Yeah.
50 volts fucking socks too.
They,
the battery,
the battery has like a like you have it so it set up so the battery doesn't it?
Wait a minute.
Talk.
Talk us through that again.
What do you,
what are you talking about?
The battle that we sell in our shows and people get shocked.
Yeah,
absolutely.
We sell them.
I don't understand $5.
It's like when you get good to like star wars,
you know they buy like three d glasses or something like that.
They have to return the mouse ears.
No,
no,
no.
Well you can't.
Cause if you get past the fucking barrier,
you're fuck just shocked and you're getting a little jolt.
So that one I'm confused.
What are they supposed to do?
And they support them back.
They're supposed to give them back to you.
Okay.
You haven't explained.
No,
no,
no.
I'm totally taking it.
Totally joking.
Sorry.
But I can't believe you took it that far and I believed I tried to help.
Terrible dark.
I Dunno,
we were comics.
We analyze it like okay,
that's could be right.
That actually is kind of bad ass though.
If you get that kind of all of garden technology and incorporating your show
any,
you're leaving a venue with like a product that,
you know,
someone who's been selling it your show.
Anyway,
I was at the supermarket and my fucking wheels locked down.
I've had that happen,
so I had like,
I had two choices.
Either I'm going to call someone and tell them,
hey,
this cart locked up or I cave man this bitch and just dragged it.
I did so I dragged it through the parking lot,
drag the shit I got to,
I did an angry man.
I that happened to me in Canada and urban home out,
what does it at home outfitters and I had a shit load of shit in there fucking
cart and I had parked far enough where I couldn't get,
I pushed the cart in the goes still the car won't go there,
more the fuck do I have a car?
And it really pisses me off because we weren't as Mexicans in Canada can help.
Two things I never do.
Hey Hammer,
Ian's going to come out.
Two things I never do.
I never purposely litter.
I never let her,
I always bring back cards
just it's not that fucking hard.
You didn't know about these fucking carts and then this is all brand new.
This is like discovery channel shift from me.
There's carts and say you can't fuck you go further than a certain distance.
Never shot up.
The carts will lock.
They literally look stupid that you can't you.
So you have to drag them.
So essentially they're on like this rubber pads and she does just grabbing it.
Is that so wrong?
I mean if I own a supermarket
amount of fucking cards and people were just going to be taking those fucking
things,
make them go out to the street just to the street.
They rang.
You got them out there.
It's,
it's like a cell phone.
I'm sure it's like one of those dog things to those dog electrical.
Yeah,
but then you get to look at the value of the fucking cart.
The cart probably costs about
$7 I would say 30 I thought if the value of having your customers not have to
fucking drag their food,
they don't offer you assistance,
they don't offer you somebody.
Okay,
sort of the cart.
We'll stop here.
We will have,
oh pull the card stops here,
plenty with the bags or continue onto your car.
Mexicans in a good robot deal this hubo baths before,
but don't steal my new band.
The best thing about the olive garden and Burbank,
Hey,
listen,
is this true robots before Mexican kids taking the Mexican jobs,
right when the Mexican starts taking over manufacturing and the worst part is
the robots are programmed by Indians,
Mexicans,
terminator,
and the worst part is the rest of America can differentiate.
You slogging it,
bitch.
There's a tour going on and no one knows about it.
Like these mics,
these new Mexicans are hairy
in there.
Ray fucking lazy tans more to start dressing up as a new Mexicans and they're
really out of movies.
These new Mexican 2.0 is are really lazy.
He's a new,
a Indian fight league,
some big India.
I,
I'm aware of it.
I know one of the guys get involved.
They're going to do an ultimate fighter as well.
Hey man,
we can't,
we can't all have conversations at the same time.
This is really exciting and invite league.
Actually,
it's going to be crazy.
I know one of the guys involved.
What is it?
There's a,
there's a new MMA series starting in India and they're having,
it's like almost like a round Robin type of thing.
Right.
I don't know what it is.
I don't know how they're going to,
it's a new company I'm not worried about.
They got this new thing called a fuck.
It's called like the world fight league or something.
Wfl they always come up with crazy names for these.
No,
but it's like,
nope.
It's
like boxing like oh for boxing.
Yeah.
It's like a box and you're like Patina in India it's called Super Fight League
did.
But this is MMA.
Yeah,
but no,
but there's,
there's the MMA one but there's also a super fight league where they have boxing
one where they have a teams from different countries that fight and then I,
exactly,
I agree.
It's not going to work if it doesn't make any fucking sense because you can't
have a solo sport font as a team.
It doesn't make any fucking drive
everywhere around,
you know,
you can have a new box did it for a while.
They had a thing called the IFL and it lasts.
Depends on the white league or something.
No.
International fights,
right?
Exotic.
Slightly exotic to the dye.
I Gene Sadik
so big in Asia,
like the Big Asian thing is one FC.
It's like dream from Japan in Southeast Asia.
It's giant.
I love FC pride.
Those are my favorites.
At first ride was awesome,
but I fucking lame man.
I will always wanted to go see really cheetahs didn't fucking smoke it well
before.
Before it went away,
man.
We knew Turi.
Remember when Tory word for them?
We had a chance,
man,
we were going to go to one of those live prides,
coordinating it all basically in most countries by organized crime fight the
fight leads.
Hey,
he just said two minutes.
We've got to look at it in this pitch.
Well,
we can come back again,
but we've got to stop this one recording.
Otherwise it's going to be corrupt,
but he gets,
it ain't anything over three hours.
You put it on iTunes and it just shits all over itself.
We'll just stop writing like blaze in the corner.
They're just fucking sound asleep.
But yeah,
it's,
it's pretty late.
Anyway.
Listen,
this has been a fantastic podcast.
We've got drunk together.
We learned a lot about each other,
right?
Eddie Bravo.
Any last thing you need to say?
Bravo.
We get out of here.
Can you give me a drum beat?
Okay,
give me a beat.
Tape,
boots.
Cats,
boots,
cat.
Ladies and gentlemen,
I just ask you to just not judge us as human beings.
Bodies show.
Don't judge us,
but don't.
Don't judge us as personalities or people with the inability to form one
coherent group of humans,
not communicating on top of each other.
It just relate and we're tired.
And we had a stress.
How?
How,
how much this podcast meant to me.
Hydro from Irvine,
California.
I did fucked up.
I was drunk,
so I had blazed drive my car from Irvine,
California to here.
And then we're going to go back to Irvine from here.
Well,
so Peter,
I wanted to see Zimmerman,
one of the baddest motherfuckers on the planet.
I want it to see Eddie Bravo.
I want to see Joe Rogan.
See you,
buddy.
I want him to see my little brother red band.
I'm always happy to see you,
Russell.
You're an awesome dude,
man.
I the first time we ever hung out in Vegas,
I'm like this,
this mother fucker.
I love him.
We had a good time and the very first time I hung out,
went up to the mix.
How do we couple cocktails and laughs.
We had some beverage headed off fabulously or they say fan and I did not want to
a freeload off you.
So I split the bottles with you.
Yeah,
we had a good time,
man.
It's true.
We had a great time.
We had fun.
What's coming up?
What do you got coming up?
Ah,
the next one is actually in Japan.
Brian's going,
hi.
Oh Shit.
A couple of weeks,
man.
It's gotta be nuts,
I'm a,
I'm,
I'm fascinated,
fascinated with,
that's going to be like,
I know.
I've never been,
it depends on what has has,
has Danny Glover gotten married yet?
Danny Glover.
You know what I'm talking about?
Listen,
look,
going be getting code right now.
We're speaking out.
That's anybody not tattling code.
I'll be right back.
That's not,
that's not code.
Everybody knows what you're saying.
Nobody knows what saying.
I have no idea what you're saying.
Tuning in.
Come on,
Ray Graham
percents.
rogan.net something something.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Listen to all the flashlights and excellent piece of masturbation material.
It's you have one handy,
like I got a bunch of box at home.
Next time you come to the house,
I'll hook you to get a flashlight going.
Mouse had I missed the coconut water though.
Oh God.
Now let me ask you a question before we go.
We're almost out of time.
How you have the mouse head and you DJ with it on,
right with a flash light.
No,
no,
no.
On a side note,
Oh,
can you do,
we don't have time for this.
We're going to the quick,
it's quick.
It's going to be crap.
Joe rogan.net thanks to the fleshlight enter in the culinary Rog,
you got a 15% off.
Go to [inaudible] dot com o and n I t makers of Alpha brain shroom tech.
Yeah.
Yada,
Yada.
And I'm in the Qa Rogan.
Get yourself 10% off.
Thanks to dead mouse for coming down here and hanging out with us and exposing
all sorts of interesting things about life.
And Eddie Bravo.
Always my brother.
Always good to hang with you.
Russell Peters.
Thanks for coming.
File these people on Twitter or not subsea.
You were growing a,
hopefully my tweets and shit.
If you're not adult,
pretend you never heard any of this shit.
We'll see you later.
Forget you.
Okay.